APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEETING TO ORDER. MISTER
CONSULT IF YOU COULD CALL THE
ROLL SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
REQUIREMENT AND I'LL DO ALL MY
NONSENSE. PORTANTINO I'M HERE
PORTANTINO HERE BATES. YEAH
BATES HERE BRADFORD. BRADFORD
HERE JONES PABLO GARC. KAMLAGER
HERE LAYERED MORE CASKEY FOR
MEMBERS WE HAVE A QUORUM AND SO
I AM THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
JOINING US ON THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS. A
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME WE
HAVE. A RELATIVELY SHORT
MEETING BY APPROPRIATIONS
STANDARDS THIS MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IN
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING A
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE IS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS THE NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. LAYER COMMITTEE
HEARING IN THE CAPITAL AND WE
DON'T HAVE ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
TODAY. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC THE TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALSWHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT THE
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEES WEBSITE WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I'LL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBERS.
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX TWO
EIGHT THREE TWO I'LL GO THROUGH
THAT AGAIN. THE PHONE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE TWO. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE TELECONFERENCE ISTOM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND-
COMMITTEE WEBSITES. WHEN WE
MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL
BE PROMPTED BY MODERATOR TO
DIAL ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR
SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION. PRESS
THIS ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN YOU A LINE NUMBER THIS
CAN BE A SHORT WAIT. ONCE YOU
RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE. FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOU FOR CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER AT THAT TIME
WILL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY INTO AVOID ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT WE HEAR FROM YOU AND
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
AGAIN PLEASE WHEN YOU'RE
PROMPTED PLEASE MUTE THE PHONE
YOUR WILL OR THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING US SO YOU CAN BE HEARD
CLEARLY. OBVIOUSLY I MAINTAIN
THE CORN DURING THE HEARINGS AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE DISRUPTIVE. MAY BE REMOVED.
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED
SO PLEASE RESPECT THAT AND
WE'LL ALL BE BETTER TODAY. IT'S
ALSO A GOOD TIME TO REMIND US
TO REMIND EVERYBODY THAT TODAY-
TESTIMONY. THIS IS A FISCAL
COMMITTEE SO IF YOU'RE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TO THE
PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
YOUR TESTIFYING ON PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM PRIOR TESTIMONY OR
RE LITIGATING THE MERITS OF THE
POLICY ISSUES BEHIND THE BILL
WE'RE JUST DISCUSSING THE
FISCAL TODAY. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS AND IT'S
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNERS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO THE NEW ONLINE
TOOL SO PLEASE EVERYBODY
PATIENT. AND RESPECTFUL WITH
THIRTY SIX BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA ALL BUT FOUR OF THEM ARE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES. AND BEFORE
WE- SO WE'VE ESTABLISHED OUR
CORN- SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
THE BUSINESS. OF THE DAY DUE TO
OUR CONSTRAINTS. HELLO OF
HEARING TAKE CAN. AND CLEANING
PROTOCOLS. OF INSTITUTING A
TIME LIMIT ON WITNESS
TESTIMONY. EACH SIDE WILL BE
PRESENT WILL BE ALLOWED TO HAVE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES. THOSE
TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES CAN DO
TWO MINUTES EACH. AT FOR THE
PRIMARY WITNESSES TWO MINUTES
EACH. ALL OTHERS TO WILLING TO
WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION. IF
NECESSARY WE WILL LIMIT THIS
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY TO TWELVE
MINUTES. FOR EACH SIDE TOTAL.
AND SO AS A REMINDER ALL
WITNESSES SHOULD LIMIT THEIR
TESTIMONY THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS
OF THE BILLS ARE MEMORY FROM ME
WITNESSES GET. UP TO TWO
MINUTES EACH AND ARMY TO
WITNESSES GET A TOTAL OF TWELVE
MINUTES PER SIDE. THE FIRST
AGENDA ITEM IS- SB FOURTEEN.
WHICH IS BY ME I'VE OBVIOUSLY
WAY PRESENTATION. AND SO IT IS
ON YOUTH MENTAL HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH- SO WE WILL
GO RIGHT TO. OUR TESTIMONY HERE
IN FORTY TWO OH THREE ON SB
FOURTEEN PORTANTINO. I SEE NO
ONE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
COMING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OF SB FOURTEEN. WILL GO NOW TO
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. I SEE NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. WISHING
TO OF. TESTIFY WILL NOW MOVE TO
PUBLIC WAITING TO TESTIFY MAY
BE A CONFERENCE. MODERATOR DO
YOU HAVE ANYONE IN THE QUEUE.
FOR SB FOURTEEN IN FAVOR.
PLEASE THIS IS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY. PLAY IS IN GERMAN
IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF AS
THE B. FOURTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF S. B. FORTY.
MISTER CARE WE HAVE NO
SUPPORTING QUEUE AT THIS TIME
ANTACID WILL NOT OPPOSITION IS
THERE ANYONE PRIMARY WITNESSES-
AND OPPOSITION I SEEN NO ONE
COMING TO THE MICROPHONE IN
THIS ROOM. I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN WE
WILL NOW GO TO THE PHONE LINE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSED SB
FOURTEEN HOURS THEIR
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
OPPOSITION OF SB FOURTEEN ONE
AND THEN. ZERO AND ONE MOMENT
WE HAVE ONE PERSON QUEUING UP
ONE MOMENT WHILE WE GIVE LOWER
THEIR LINE NUMBER. THANK.
SENATOR IN MIND OR DID ONE AND
THEN ZERO. FOR ANY OPPOSITION
OF S. B. FOURTEEN. AND WE WILL
GO TO THE LINE NUMBER OF. LINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
WANT. TO S. B. EIGHTY TWO WE'RE
NOT ON THE BILL. RIGHT S.
HEALTHCARE TEAM SB EIGHTY TWO
IS LATER IN THE IN. IN THE DAYS.
BUT IT'S NOT ON A REMINDER AS
TO BE FOURTEEN AND OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT- ANYONE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS. WE HAVE TAKEN
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION. SB
FOURTEEN- C. FIVE SETS BERMAN
FINANCED IS NOT HAVE A FILE IN
SB FOURTEEN TO ANYBODY IN THIS
ROOM HAVE A QUESTION SAYING
NINE WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
FOURTEEN WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO SB FIFTEEN ALSO BY
ME I WAY PRESENTATION THIS IS
ON HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AND
RETAIL SITES- IF THERE'S ANYONE
IN THIS ROOM WHO WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTEEN NOW IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY.
GO AHEAD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE STATE BUILING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU NO ONE ELSE IS IN THIS ROOM
IN SUPPORT SAYING NO ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OUR PHONE LINE FOR
SB FIFTEEN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
AND ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE
DO HAVE QUITE A FEW KEY ONE.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE GOING TO-
LIMIT TESTIMONY TO TWELVE
MINUTES. OKAY AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE UP BY LINE SEVENTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FOR SB FIFTEEN.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN LINE
SEVENTEEN. HELLO YOU MEET RIGHT
NOW IS NOT A REGARDING S. B.
EIGHTY TWO RONDELL. BROWN SB
FIFTEEN PLEASE WAIT FOR SB
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU AND WE'LL
GO TO LINE UP TO THIRTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI JENNIFER
TANNER INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA.
IN SUPPORT OF THAT FIFTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND NEXT
TO THE LINE OF FORTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS CHRIS WILSON WITH THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BUSINESS
FEDERATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANEXO GOAL LINE
OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I LEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND THE
FUNDING TO IMPLEMENT IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOUR MEMBERS MIKE MONEY GOING
TO BE HAPPY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL. IN THE WESTERN STATE
COUNCIL SHEET METAL WORKERS NOT
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS HOLLY
OSBORNE I'M A RESIDENT OF
REDONDO BEACH AND A MEMBER OF
UNITED NEIGHBORS IN SUPPORT OF
THE FIFTEEN. THANK YOU AND
MEXICO LINE OF THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
TODD SNYDER INDIVISIBLE SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT OF FULLY
FUNDING AND IMPLEMENTING SB
FIFTEEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AND AS A REMINDER WE ARE ON S.
B. FIFTEEN IN SUPPORT AND THAT
YOU MADE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO TO GET INTO Q. AND NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWENTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME
IS MILO LINGERED I AM IN SAN
DIEGO AT THE INDIVISIBLE AND
SAN DIEGO THREE FIFTY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SB FIFTEEN.
I SEE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED- I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MISTER MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION SP FIFTEEN NOW IS
THEIR TIME TO SPEAK. THANK YOU
AND IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
SB FIFTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO. ONE MOMENT. PINE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN HI MY NAME OF
THE SITE AND I'M WITH THE HYDE
PARK ORGANIZATIONAL PARTNERSHIP
FOR EMPOWERMENT AND SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND I AM OPPOSING- SB
FIFTEEN IN ITS CURRENT FORM
BECAUSE WE AS A COMMUNITY ARE
HAVING MAJOR ISSUES WITH
MAINTAINING OUR COMMERCIAL
QUARTERS WE'VE BEEN OVER RUN BY
HOUSING THAT IS NOT AFFORDABLE
FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND IS
TOTALLY YOUR ROLE IN OUR
COMMERCIAL CORRIDOR WENEED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT OUR COMMUNITY
HAS THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
MAINTAIN ITS ECONOMIC CORRIDOR
BECAUSE OTHER THAN THAT WE
CANNOT MAINTAIN ANY ECONOMIC
VIABILITY FOR OUR COMMUNITY IN
ITS CURRENT FORM WE HAVE A
PROBLEM IF WE HAD LIKE 1100%
COMMERCIAL GROUND FLOOR IT
WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT WE
COULD LOOK AT THAT IN ITS
CURRENT FORM OFFERS INCENTIVES
FOR PUTTING 1100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WHERE THERE ARE EMPTY
COMMERCIAL SPACES WE CANNOT.
SUPPORT IT SO WE ARE OPPOSED TO
IT. IN ITS CURRENT FORM THANK
YOU. NOW CONSIDER THAT A
PRIMARY WITNESS REST ME TO USE.
THANK YOU AND WE ARE BOTTLE
NEXT TO LINE OF FIFTEEN. THIS
IS WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING SINCE
I'M A MEMBER OF THE PARK MESA
HEIGHTS COMMUNITY COUNCIL
CALLING- AS AN INDIVIDUAL THIS
MORNING AND- OPPOSITION BASED
ON THE PREVIOUS SCHOLARS
COMMENTS. THANK YOU. WITH AND
WE ARE DOING S. B. FIFTEEN OF
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO TO GET INTO Q. AN
ACTUAL GOAL LINE OF FIFTY. ONE
FIFTY DROPS WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION'S IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THE PHARMA
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE ON SD
FIFTEEN SO WE'LL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE. SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP WITHOUT OBJECTION S. C.
FIFTEEN WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
LEVINE S. B. TWO TWO FOUR ALSO
BY ME PORTANTINO ON MENTAL
HEALTH EDUCATION I'VE WAY
PRESENTATION- THIS IS ALSO A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE AND WE'LL
SEXY NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO TWO FOUR. I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR FEW PICKS YOU UP
ANYBODY WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO FOUR.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TO FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FJORDS
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TWO FOUR.
AND ONE MOMENT MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE A FEW DIALING IN. AND WE
WILL GO TO OUR FIRST LINE OF
LINE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING RICHARD A COUPLE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH LAW
COULD SPONSORING AND IS THE
COURT AND SB PEACHY FOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO TO FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT
IN Q. MR ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT
OPPOSITION FOR S. B. TWO TWO
FOUR SEEING NO ONE IN. THIS
ROOM. COMING TO THE MICROPHONES
IN NOBODY IN THAT ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. WE WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINE NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
OPPOSITION S. B. TWO TWO FOUR.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO TO FOUR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. TWO TO FOUR YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THE FUTURE ALL RIGHT WE
WILL NOW COME BACK IT'S MY
MISSION IS PARTMINER FINANCE
DOES HAVE A FILE ON S. B. TWO
TWO FOUR. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DELEON AYE DODD WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL.
AT THIS TIME I WOULD NOTE THAT
THE BILL COULD CREATE A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE.
ACCRETING COSTS IN THE RANGE
FROM LOW MILLIONS TO KNOW TENS
OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND. BY REQUIRING
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL EDUCATION
SEIZE TERRIFIED ALL PEOPLES
WITH MENTAL HEALTH INSTRUCTION.
A MINIMAL THREE TIMES OVER THE
COURSE OF THEIR EDUCATION. A
FURTHER BY REQUIRING CHARTER
SCHOOLS TO IMPLEMENT- METAL
CONSTRUCTION THIS BILL COULD
ALSO CREATE COST PRESSURES TO
INCREASE THE MANDATES BLOCK
GRANT ALLOCATION. FOR CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THIS CONSTANT ESTIMATE
ASSUMES THAT EXISTING TEACHERS
WOULD PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
INSTRUCTION WITH AN EXISTING
CLASS TIME. HOWEVER A SCHOOLS
MAY HIRE OUTSIDE INSTRUCTORS
WHICH COULD ALSO POTENTIALLY
INCREASE COSTS. AND COST COULD
VARY WIDELY DEPENDING ON HOW
SCHOOLS SHOULD IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL. LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION INDICATES THE BILL
DOES NOT SPECIFY ANY
REQUIREMENTS RELATED OVERSIGHT
REPORTING AND WOULD NOT CREATE
ADDITIONAL COST TO THE EXTENT
THE DEPARTMENT IS NOT REQUIRED.
TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE OR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE RELATED TO
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU REGARD
FROM FINANCE WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE PUBLIC I SEE NO HANDS GO UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION. S. B. TWO
TWO FOUR WILL MOVE TO SUSPENSE
MOVING FURNITURE DODD THREE
BILLS- I DON'T THINK WE CAN
TAKE THEM OUT OF ORDER CAN WE
MARK. CAN WE HAVE TO GO IN
ORDER. WE HAVE TO GO IN ORDER
BILL SO IT'S GONNA BE ABOUT
ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES I
APOLOGIZE FOR. ALL RIGHT WE'LL
MOVE TO SB TWENTY MISTER GOD
STUDENT NUTRITION CAL FRESH
MISTER DOLLARS WAY PRESENTATION
ON SB TWENTY I SEE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT- MISSED MODERATOR P.
WOULD QUEUE UP ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY DIED
STUDENT ATTRITION NOW'S YOUR
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY.
AND ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON IN Q. AND JUST A
REMINDER TO ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR S. B. TWENTY IN SUPPORT.
AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
SHE GOOD MORNING MODELING
COOPER FROM THE OPEN MARKET
MURDER ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT
OPPOSITION RECIPE TWENTY SEEING
NO ONE AND FORTY TWO OH THREE
AND IN OPPOSITION SEEING NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
OPPOSITION MODERATOR KEEP COULD
CURE ANYBODY OPPOSED SB TWENTY
NOW IS THEIR TIME. THANK YOU
BEEN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWENTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE AN
OPPOSITION OF SB. TWENTY MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NOT POSITIONING
QUEUE AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT-
THE DEPARTMENT FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON S. B. TWENTY
THING OUT OF MY COLLEAGUES WITH
THEIR HANDS UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWENTY WILL GO TO
SUSPEND SPENDING ON S. B. TWO
OH FOUR BY MR TODD. WHO'S ALSO
A PRESENTATION THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SAYING NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
AND SUPPORTS YOU KNOW ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
MODERATOR COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE
ON THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO OH FOUR ON ELECTRICITY.
CITY DEMAND RESPONSE. THANK YOU
IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO ZERO OR YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO ZERO FOUR. AND WE
HAVE. ONE IN Q. ONE MOMENT FOR
THAT LINE NUMBER. YOU KNOW WE
ARE IN S. B. TWO ZERO FOUR IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND THAT LINE NUMBER
IS A THREE THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES MORE ENGAGEMENT ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA MADE
ACTIONS TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT OF SB TOOL FOR. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WHEN I MOVED
OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM AT THE MICROPHONE OPPOSED
S. B. TWO OH FOUR I SEE NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED.
SB TWO OH FOUR IS THERE ANYONE
ONLINE OPPOSED S. B. TWO OH
FOUR. THANK YOU INTERFERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TOOL FOR YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO OH FOUR.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ANTARCTICA PARTMINER
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE ON S.
B. TWO OH FOUR. MY COLLEAGUES
DO NOT HAVE THEIR HANDS UP
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TOOL FOR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MISTER DIED
OF IT COME UP AND TELL US ABOUT
SB EIGHT ONE EIGHT- GEO
COMMITTEE BILL. ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LOTTERY-
THAT'S OUR NEXT ITEM THE
RECOMMENDATION IS A TO PASS. A
RESTAURANT IF YOU COULD TELL US
ABOUT. S. B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
S. B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT IS THE
SENATE GEO COMMITTEE BILL THAT
SIMPLY IMPLEMENT SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE DETAILED.
IN LAST YEAR'S AUDITOR'S REPORT
DETAILING THE LOTTERY'S FAILURE
TO ENSURE THE USE OF UP TO DATE
INFORMATION TO DETERMINE THE
OPTIMAL PRIZE PAY OUT. BY
REQUIRE THAT THE LOTTERY
CONDUCTED STUDY EVERY FIVE
YEARS TO DETERMINE THE OPTIMAL
PRIZE PAYOUT WE WILL ENSURE THE
MAXIMUM OUT OF MONEY GOES TO
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS. ACCORDING
TO YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE
BILL HAS MINOR COSTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
MISTER DODD. I SEE NO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM I SEE
NO WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR FIFTY TWO OF
ANYBODY. IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
ONE EIGHT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
EIGHT ONE EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE NO SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WILL NOW GO
TO THE OPPOSITION I SEE NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED SB EIGHT
ONE EIGHT I SEE NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. CLOSEST FREE ONE
EIGHT MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE LINE OPPOSED SB EIGHT ONE
EIGHT. THANK YOU. IN OPPOSITION
OF OUR S. B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT.
MY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION. OF SB. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER ALL
RIGHT- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE IN SB
EIGHT ONE EIGHT I SEE NONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES MISTER LEONARD
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ME YOU'RE
GOOD. I'M GOOD I'M READY IF YOU
KNOW THE MOTION HI ALL RIGHT
MISTER TODD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE FACT LAST RIVAL MISTER
LEONARD IS READY I MOVED TO
PASS OKAY THE RAP MOTION IS TO
PASS A EIGHT ONE EIGHT- MR.
ALTMAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
EIGHT ONE EIGHT OUR MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO HI
BATES. BATES FIVE BRADFORD.
JONES JONES FIVE COM LONGER.
LAYERED BY LAYERED I WHITE
HOUSE SKI. IT WAS FOR US THE
LAST FOUR ROAD TO KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR- OTHER MEMBERS AND
THANK YOU MISTER DOT FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I REMEMBER YOU GUYS.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO MAYES RUBIO THREE BILLS
STARTING WITH S. B. TWENTY
THREE. WHICH IS A DISORDERLY
CONDUCT STATUTE LIMITATIONS FOR
DISTRIBUTION OF INTIMATE IMAGES
INTIMATE IMAGES- SORRY NEXT
ITEM- IT IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE MAYES RUBIO IS WAY
PRESENTATION SO WE'LL MOVE
RIGHT TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY.
I SEE NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWENTY THREE I SEE NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND I. GO NOW
TO THE PHONE LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY THREE.
BY MS RUBIO. THANK YOU IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWENTY THREE. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO SUPPORT QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WHEN I
GOT OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY
THREE SAYING NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM GOING TO TWENTY FORTY
SEEING NO ONE THERE. MODERATOR
FIFTY Q. OF ANYONE ON THE LINE
IN OPPOSITION S. B. TWENTY
THREE. THANK YOU AND IF YOU'RE
NOT THE VISION OF S. B. TWENTY
THREE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE ZERO IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. TWENTY THREE.
AND WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER. ALL
RIGHTS WE WILL FARMING FINANCED
IS NOT HAVE A FILE IN SB TWENTY
THREE WILL COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NO HANDS GO
UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWENTY
THREE WILL GO TO. SUSPENSE WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR NEXT ITEM
WHICH IS S. B. SEVENTY- IS
RUBIO IS WAY PRESENTATION THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. AND
WILL MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY WITH FOR ANYONE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM. IS
KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY-
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVENTY. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT OF SB
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO NOW. ONE AND THEN
ZERO OF YOUR IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SEVENTY. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'VE GIVEN THE
SUPPORTERS THE OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY I
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE MISTER
NATHAN PEERS FROM THE SENIOR
LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FROM HIGH
PRIVATE HOME EDUCATORS OF
CALIFORNI. ON THE COAST LINE
HE'S OUR PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESS MR PEERS YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES SEVEN OR TOTAL OF FOUR
MINUTES IF YOU'RE THE ONLY-
PRIMARY WITNESS SO MR PEERS ARE
YOU THERE. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME
I CAN. EXCELLENT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAKING
PEERS HERE FOR PRIVATE HOME
EDUCATORS IN CALIFORNIA- AS
THE- THE ANALYSIS NOTED THAT-
THIS WILL IMPACT FIFTEEN.
FIFTEEN TO THIRTY THOUSAND
KINDERGARTEN AGE CHILDREN OF
THAT ARE NOT CURRENTLY REQUIRED
TO ATTEND KINDERGARTEN. TO MAKE
THAT MANDATORY FOR THEM WOULD
REQUIRE THAT NUMBER. FIFTEEN TO
THIRTY THOUSAND CHILDREN TO
ATTEND KINDERGARTEN- WITH THE
POSSIBILITY OF THEM BEING IN
PUBLIC SCHOOLS- AT THAT GRADE
LEVEL. THAT WOULD- INCREASE
COSTS AND EDA FUNDING.
POTENTIALLY TWO HUNDRED TO FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION. BEGINNING IN
THE TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
FISCAL YEAR. BUT IN ADDITION TO
THAT I JUST WANTED TO POINT OUT
OF THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE-
WITH REGARD TO THE FINANCES.
WOULD BE FIVE SB SEVENTY WOULD
ALSO PLACING HIM IN APPROPRIATE
FINANCIAL BURDEN ON PARENTS WHO
HAVE DETERMINED THAT IS IN THE
BEST INTERESTS AND THEIR CHILD
TO ATTEND A PRIVATE SCHOOL AT
THEIR OWN EXPENSE AT THE
KINDERGARTEN LEVEL. OF THESE
PARENTS WOULD BE PAYING FOR ONE
ADDITIONAL YEAR OF REQUIRED
EDUCATION FOR THEIR CHILD SO
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A NOTE OF THAT
AS WELL IN ADDITION TO. THE
DIRECT STATE FUNDING THIS IS.
FUNDING THAT WOULD BE YOUR- IT.
WOULD AFFECT THE ECONOMY OF
INDIVIDUAL FAMILIES. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU F.
MODERATOR Q. OF ARMY TO
TESTIMONY NOW IS THEIR TIME FOR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTY MY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO HERE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SEVENTY. AND
ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE A LINE
COMING IN Q. NAZARIAN MINDER IT
IS THE ONE AND THEN ZERO HERE
IN OPPOSITION UP S. B. SEVENTY.
ONE MOMENT WE'RE GETTING LINE
NUMBER. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
FORTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHINA
BASICALLY AND I AM A SPECIAL
EDUCATION TEACHER IN ROSEVILLE
CALIFORNIA AND I OPPOSE SB
SEVENTY. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE
NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL
RIGHT I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT BE A KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
WAS NOBODY IN FORTY TWO OH
THREE OPPOSED SB SEVENTY. AND
THERE IS NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY- OPPOSED SB SEVENTY AND
WE TAKE IN BOTH SUPPORT AND
OPPOSE. OPPORTUNITIES FROM OUR
PHONE LINE I WILL GO TO
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH
DOES HAVE A FILE ON SB SEVENTY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THIS BILL
BUT WOULD NOT THAT BY
INCREASING THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IN PUBLIC SCHOOL THE
BILL INCREASES THE PORTION IT
COSTS. FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL.
FUNDING FORMULA BY ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO MILLION TO ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO MILLION
DOLLARS ON GOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND.
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE. THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEE IS LIKELY TO
REMAIN IN A TEST ONE
CALCULATION UNDER THE CURRENT
FORECAST. MEANING IS NOT
ADJUSTED FOR CHANGES IN
ATTENDANCE EVEN WITH THE
INCREASE IN EIGHTY EIGHT
RESULTING FROM THE SPILL. THERE
FOR THE INCREASED COST TO THE
LCF FROM THIS BILL WOULD NOT BE
OFFSET BY OUR PROPORTIONATE
INCREASE IN AVAILABLE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
FUNDING. I WOULD CREDIT
AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR OTHER K.
THROUGH TWELVE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT FUNDED PROGRAMS.
WE KNOW THAT ALTHOUGH THIS BILL
CREATES A STATE MANDATED
PROGRAM. THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE REQUIRED SERVICES
WOULD BE FUNDED THROUGH LCF AND
SPECIAL EDUCATION OF COURSE
ENTITLEMENTS. WHICH WILL OFFSET
THE MANDATE THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE
IT WILL COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE I SEE NO HANDS GO UP.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB SEVENTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE MOVED
SB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT ALSO BY MS
RUBY ON TEACHER CREDENTIALING.
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
AND RESERVADOS WAY PRESENTATION
SO MOVE RIGHT TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY I SEE NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE. I SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT- FOLKS WAITING ON THE
TELECONFERENCE I NOW IS YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU AND IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
NOW. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF SIXTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE SIXTY SEVEN. M. I. LINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE LADY
EARLIER THAT WAS SO RUDE I
CALLING AGAINST SEVENTY AND YOU
DON'T PLACE IT'S INTUITIVE ALL
YOU FORMING STRAIN TO CALL IN
INCLUDING ME AND TRYING AGAIN
SB SEVENTY NOW ANOTHERBILL IS
UP AND YOU PEOPLE. SHOULDN'T
MODERATOR THANK YOU. WHICH THE-
WHAT IF CALIFORNIANS I READ I
DON'T IF YOU COULD PLEASE GIVE
EACH MA'AM MA'AM IF YOU COULD
JUST SAY YOUR NAME THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT LET'S GO TO LINE OF
SIXTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SHOP
AROUND WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATE
CALLING INTO COURT AND SB FOUR
EIGHTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND WE HAVE NO THERE ARE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THEN LET US GO TO
OPPOSITION. TO HAVE ANY ARE.
FOLKS IN THIS ROOM WHO LEADS TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE
ANY AND I CAN'T SEE ABOUT ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. I AM ASSUMING. NO
ONE NO ONE ISN'T THERE NO ONE'S
IN TWENTY FORTY THEN LET'S GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY. WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU'RE NOT THE VISION OF
SB FOUR EIGHT EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE OF SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINES OPEN. ONE SIXTY SIX
AND I AM STILL SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO BE SEVENTY AND-
THERE SHOULD NOT. ONE DIDN'T.
PERFECTLY MIKE TEACHER HUSBAND
GOING TO GET THIS BILL AGAIN
THIS BILL. PLEASE AND WE'RE
CALLING IT THE PERFECT TIME
BECAUSE YOU TAKE THIS INTO A
DIFFERENT. YOU MAKE IT
COMPLICATED WE ARE PROFESSIONAL.
WE ON BEHALF. ANY NUMBER. OF
FAMILIES. NOW REPRESENTED OVER
THE YEARS AS KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER WHO WITH THE
LEGISLATION. MORE USER FRIENDLY
IN THE FUTURE PLEASE. THANK YOU
NEXT SPEAKER IF. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. THANK THEM WILL GO
TO FINANCE I DON'T SEE ANYONE
ON WHO WISHES TO GIVE US A
REPORT. THERE'S NO FILE. THEN
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL THIS
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING ON
TO ITEM NUMBER TEN IS S. B.
TWENTY SIX IT IS A ALL CUT
CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE. FOLLOW
YEAH YEAH. DO WE HAVE OF
SPEAKERS. C. NINE AND FORTY IN
THIS ROOM NINE IN TWENTY FORTY.
MADAME MODERATOR DO WE HAVE OF
WITNESSES ON LINE THAT WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWENTY SIX YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO ONE SB TWENTY
SIX. THEY HAVE NO SUPPORT IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THE FIRM
YEAH AWARENESS. WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
FOR S. B. TWENTY SIX. GOD
OPPOSITION FOR SB TWENTY SIX
THING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED SB. TWENTY SIX WILL
SING KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSED SB TWENTY SIX. WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWENTY SIX.
THANK YOU IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWENTY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE OPPOSITION SB.
TWENTY SIX. AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. IT'S TERRIBLE. GO TO
PARMA FINANCES NOT OF A FILING
SB TWENTY SIX OR BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE SEEING NO
HANDS GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB TWENTY SIX. WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
SB EIGHTY TWO SKINNER ON PETTY
THEFT. SKINNER HAS A WAY
PRESENTATION AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. OBVIOUSLY
AGAIN WE'RE GOING TO LIMIT OUR
TESTIMONY FOR PRIMARY TESTIMONY.
THE FOUR MINUTES PER SIDE AND
WE'RE GONNA LIMIT ANY ME TO
TESTIMONY TO TWELVE MINUTES FOR
EACH SIDE. SO WE WILL GO TO TAX
MONEY TO SUPPORT SB EIGHTY TWO
I SEE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY TWO. I SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHTY TWO. AND
MODERATOR PLEASE GO TO OUR
PHONE LINE. FOR SB EIGHTY TO
SUPPORT NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU IF YOU AREN'T. IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHTY TWO YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF SIXTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERS CURSING
THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT PASSED
EACH EIGHTY TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND IT IS ONE AND
THEN ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. EIGHTY TWO. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT- I
KNOW WE HAVE SOME PRIMARY
WITNESSES THAT WERE. CALL THEN
ARE YOU. DR KIM OR YOU RYAN
COUZENS RIGHT THAT PRESENTS
OKAY- ALL RIGHT MR COUSINS I
THINK WE'RE WAITING ON DR KIM
SO MR COUSINS IF YOU COULD USE
YOUR OPPORTUNITY AND CONFINE
YOURSELF TO TWO MINUTES THAT
WOULD BE GREAT. THANK YOU SIR-
GOOD MORNING DISTINGUISHED
PANEL MY NAME IS RYAN COUSINS
I'M AN ASSISTANT CHIEF DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY WITH YOU'LL
COUNTY CALIFORNIA. THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF S. B. EIGHTY TWO WILL
BE THAT IT WILL TELL EVERY
THIEF IN CALIFORNIA. THAT YOU
CAN USE FORCE TO STEAL AND AS
LONG AS YOU DON'T INFLICT GREAT
BODILY INJURY YOU WILL GET A
MISDEMEANOR PETTY THEFT.
MISDEMEANOR PETTY THEFT DON'T
DETER. SERIOUS THEMES WE HAVE
THE TESTIMONY FROM THE THIEVES
THEMSELVES THE ESTABLISHED THAT
SO THIS WILL AND CAUSE AN
INCREASE IN ROBBERIES BECAUSE
ROBBERIES ARE MORE LUCRATIVE.
AND THIS WILL MOVE THE RISK YOU
GET THE BEST STUFF WITH
ROBBERIES PURSES AND WALLETS.
THERE WERE 200-008-0040 NINE
STRONG ARM ROBBERIES WHICH IS
WHAT THESE WOULD BE- IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN IF THIS
CAUSED A 10% INCREASE IN
ROBBERIES. THE MARGINAL COST
FOR POLICE RESPONSE WOULD BE AN
ADDITIONAL ANNUAL COST OF SEVEN
POINT NINE EIGHT MILLION THAT
WOULD BE CONSERVATIVE THAT'S
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
CALIFORNIA IS OBVIOUSLY MORE
EXPENSIVE. IF THAT WITH THAT
10% INCREASE THE VICTIMS OF
CRIME BOARD PAYOUTS TO VICTIMS
OF THESE ADDITIONAL ROBBERIES
WOULD BE FOUR POINT ONE NINE
SEVEN. IT'S LIKELY THE INCREASE
WILL BE MORE COMMENSURATE WITH
THE INCREASE OF LARCENY THEFT
THAT HAPPENED WITH PROP FORTY
SEVEN. THAT THAT'S THE CASE
THAT WOULD BE A 27% INCREASE
WHICH WOULD BE. A PLUS TWENTY
ONE POINT FIVE SIX MILLION A
MARGINAL COSTS FOR POLICE
RESPONSE. AT ELEVEN POINT THREE
THREE MILLION IN POTENTIAL
VICTIM REIMBURSEMENTS AS IF
EVERYONE APPLIED. THE AUTHOR
HAS SAID THAT. IF THESE
ADDITIONAL ROBBERIES OCCUR AND
ASSAULTS HAPPENED THOSE
ASSAULTS CAN BE CHARGED AS
FELONIES. THAT PROVIDES EVEN
MORE OF AN EXPENSE WITH AGAIN
WITH THAT 10% INCREASE. IT
WOULD BE PLUS TWENTY NINE POINT
FIVE MILLION A MARGINAL COSTS
FOR POLICE. AND FOUR MILLION
FOR POTENTIAL VICTIM
REIMBURSEMENTS WITH A 27%
INCREASE IT WOULD BE PLUS.
SEVENTY NINE MILLION A MARGINAL
PLEASE COSTS AND TEN POINT NINE
MILLION IN VICTIM
REIMBURSEMENTS. NONE OF THIS
INCLUDES THE COST TO BRING
PEOPLE BACK FROM THE PRISON.
AND THE INCREDIBLE COST TO
VICTIMS THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
DO WE HAVE A PROFESSOR CAME ON
THE LINE. I DON'T BUT IF YOU
WERE ON THE LINE AS A
PARTICIPANT. DR KIM YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AND WE
WILL OPEN YOUR LINE. ALL RIGHT
WE DO NOT HAVE DOCTOR CAME WITH
US- SO WE WILL GO BACK TO OUR
NORMAL COURSE OF OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY I SEE NO ONE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE. OPPOSED I SEE
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. SO
MODERATOR NOW IS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS SUPPOSED
TO S. B. EIGHTY TWO TO SPEAK WE
WANT TO CONFINE THEIR TESTIMONY
TO THEIR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
IN THAT POSITION. FOR A TOTAL
OF TWELVE MINUTES AND IF DR KIM
COMES DURING THIS TIME WE WILL
GIVE HIM A COURTESY. BUT LET'S
GO TO OUR GENERAL OPPOSITION
TESTIMONY FOR NAME OCCUPATION
NAME REPRESENTATION AND
POSITION SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
THEY'RE OFF IN OPPOSITION OF S.
B. EIGHTY TWO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR S. B. EIGHTY TWO. AND
WE WILL GO TO A LINE OF SEVENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI MY
NAME'S CLEAN. UP I'M IN HOLE
FOR A ONE NIGHT AYE OPPOSED SB
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE BE PASSED ON
CRIMES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
EXTRA LINE OF FORTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS MAINLY
YOUNG I'M NOT CONCERNED- CARE
GIVER PLEASE SAY NO TO. S. B.
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU NEXT ON
THE LINE OF TWENTY SIX SALINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
ROBERTO RAMIREZ SANCHEZ IN
SEKARAN CALIFORNIA I AM THE CO
CHAIR OF THE VOICES FOR VICTIMS
COALITION BEGIN ON MY OWN
BEHALF IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL AND THE FUNDING REQUIRED
TO IMPLEMENT IT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AN EXTRA LINE OF
TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS PATRICK
CAMPBELL THANK YOU CHAIRPERSON
FOR GIVING ME THIS TIME IN
REVIEWING THE BILL SUMMARY THE
CARPETED JUSTICE REPORT RIGHT
SIR WE'RE ON YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION. THAT'S NOT DOCTOR
CAME IS IT AT. HELLO NO THIS
OKAY SO JUST TO JUST YOUR NAME
YOUR ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION SIR. HEY PATRICK
CAMPBELL LOCALLY ATION- EIGHT
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE AND WOULD
LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPLAIN
WHY IT'S GIVEN TWO MINUTES TO
DO SO NOW SURE YOU CAN SEND IN
YOUR COMMENTS. WE HAVE TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES THAT WERE
SCHEDULED IN YOUR IN THE IN THE
WHAT WE CALL THE ME TO SEGMENT
SO WE'D BE HAPPY TO RECEIVE
YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS AND PUT
HIM IN THE RECORD BUT THIS IS
THE TIME FOR ME TOO. BECAUSE WE
HAVE A PRE ARRANGED PRIMARY
SPEAKER DR KIM. SO THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT MODERATOR. BUT FINE
WILL GO TO IS SIXTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS
IS PATRICK ESPINOSA THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB. EIGHTY TWO. EXTRA LINE
OF SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NINE SEVENTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY AND WILL GO
ON THE LINE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND GIVE ME. YES
WE CAN YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
OKAY THIS IS A QUESTION I'M A
HOUSEWIFE I THINK NO TO SB
EIGHTY TWO. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YEAH YEAH. HELLO I AM
VERY NAY. I AM A OF BREAKING
OPPOSE AT THE EIGHTY TWO. THANK
YOU AS A REMINDER WE ARE ON S.
B. EIGHTY TWO OPPOSITION YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND THE NEXT FINAL COME FROM
SIXTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE WILL GO
TO A LINE OF EIGHTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALL MY ENEMY OF
MY ENEMY TO DEANNA I THANK
YOUNG OPPOSE SB AGE YOU ARE
WERE AND THE COMMUNITY IT HAS
BEING. IMPORTANT BECAUSE OF TE
CRIME INCREASED CRIME I AM
REALLY CONCERNED THAT OP EIGHT
EIGHT AT THE EIGHTY EIGHT ZERO
HI DO YOU HAVE CRIMES THANK YOU
WERE JUST TAKING YOUR NAME YOUR
ORGANIZATION. AND YOUR POSITION
AT THIS POINT. SO YOUR PO THE
BILL. THANK YOU NEXT PICKER.
THANK YOU AND WE WILL GO ONLINE
OF EIGHTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS JESSICA
SAW ON BEHALF OF ALL MOM I KNOW
I STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. EIGHTY
TWO THANK YOU. AND THE COVER
LINE OF SEVENTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YES HI MY NAME
IS A STUDENT WELL- CALLING ON
BEHALF OF A BETTER COMMUNITY
REPRESENTING HUNDREDS OF OUR-
PARENTS- USING PAPER VALLEY AND
WE ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO S.
B. EIGHTY TWO WHICH IS VERY-
FOR TO OUR COMMUNITY. THANK YOU.
YOU. WHEN MY MINOR REMINDER WE
ARE ON S. B. EIGHTY TWO IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. STILL ONE ONE
MOMENT WE HAVE ONE MORE THANK
YOU. I REQUEST YOU MARIN QUEUE
NOW ONE MOMENT PLEASE. WE WILL
GO LINE OF EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING CARE
MEMBERS PERSONAL TO DOS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WE WILL GO TO
THE LINE OF A SEVENTY THREE
YEAR LINE OF THE OPEN. HI THIS
IS SHANNON CALLING FROM THE
PARK MAJOR HYPE COMMUNITY AREA
ON CLEAR STRONGLY IN OPPOSITION
TO. YEAH THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NXR THE LINE OF EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GREEN PLAINS
I STRONGLY OPPOSE. A. B. AB
TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITIONS
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME MISTER
CHAIR ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM BOTH THE SPOT WELDED
MISTER KIM EVER. SHOW UP. MR
KIM DID NOT SHOW UP. I WAS
EXCEPTIONAL YEAH THANK HI-
THAT'S FINE WE GAVE HIM HOUR IN
A CURTIS AND SO WE'VE HEARD
BOTH THE SUPPORT AND- WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE ON S. B. EIGHTY TWO AND WE
WILL COME BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SPD TO. GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO WELL LET'S
GET NOW ARE WILL GO TO SB
THIRTY EIGHT- MOVING TO SB
THIRTY EIGHT FIRE COLLEAGUES MR
WHY CASKEY WHO HAS. WAIVED
PRESENTATION ON HIS BILLS AND
MORE MOVE RIGHT TO THEPUBLIC
TESTIMONY WISHING FOR ANYONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT THERE IS NO
ONE IN ROOM FOR THIS BY THE WAY
IS ON BEVERAGE CONTAINERS SB
THIRTY EIGHT THERE'S NO ONE IN
SB. FORTY TWO OH THREE THERE'S
NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANYONE IN
THE QUEUE- TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF SB THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOT
COME TO OPPOSITION SAYING NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
OPPOSED SB THIRTY EIGHT. WE
MOVED TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE LINE OPPOSED SB THIRTY
EIGHT. IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF
SB. THIRTY EIGHT. AND WE WILL
GO LINE OF SEVENTY FOUR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES I'M CALLING
TO- OPPOSE SB THIRTY EIGHT
HOURS EVEN GROWN FROM MONTANA
COMMUNITY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND THE NEXT LINE WILL GO TO A
SIXTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YES THIS IS DOMINO ROW- WHAT'S
IN AMERICA'S BACKING ON THE
OLDEST BLACK OWNED COMPANIES
HERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WE
OPPOSED SB. THIRTY EIGHT. THANK
YOU AND IF YOUR NOT POSITION OF
SB THIRTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE ONE MARKET ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. AGAIN AT THE ONE
AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF
SB THIRTY EIGHT. AND WE WILL GO
A LONG NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS LEONARD LANG
I'M WITH- UPPER ROOM CONSULTING
I ADVISE RECYCLERS AND
PROCESSORS AROUND THE STATE I'M
IN OPPOSITION THIS BILL WILL
CREATE MORE WORK FOR THE
DIVISION OF RECYCLING TO
OVERSEE. THOUSANDS OF STORES
AND RETAILERS AND- IT WILL
AVOID THE REAL GOAL OF THE
PROPERTY ISSUE WHICH IS LATER
THESE MACHINES ARE AS THE
AUTHORS STATED DO NOT ACCEPT
DAMAGED CONFIGURATOR WHAT WE GO
TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL COME
BACK TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE ON SB THIRTY EIGHT. WE'VE
HEARD FROM SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION- I SEE NO HAN SO.
I'M SORRY OUR- THEY SAY THEY DO
HAVE A FILE MY MISTAKE. SEE
THAT I WAS THAT I MESSED UP
JOEY. TELL YOURS. PHYSICIAN ON
THE BILL AT THIS TIME WHICH IS
NOT THE CALIBER RECYCLE
ESTIMATES THAT WORKLOAD TO
OVERSEE THAT CONTAINER
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION- AND
TO ENFORCE THE VARIOUS
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WOULD
REQUIRE CAL RECYCLE TO MAINTAIN
THEIR EXISTING STAFFING LEVELS-
UNTIL THE TRANSITION IS
COMPLETE THIS CONSISTENT BUT TO
EARN TWENTY TWO POSITIONS AND
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. TO PRIMARILY PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND ENFORCEMENT OF
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM AND THE
ESTIMATE AN ADDITIONAL NINE TO
SEVENTEEN LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS TO ASSIST WITH THE
TRANSITION. AND TO PERMANENT.
TO DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A NEW
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY SYSTEM
TAILORED TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL AND REPLACE THE
DIVISION OF RECYCLING
INTEGRATED INFORMATION SYSTEM.
ALTHOUGH THE TIMING AND COST OF
THESE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES NOT
CLEAR AT THIS TIME ACOSTA
ESTIMATED TO BE UP TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FROM
THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING FUND. UNTIL THE
TRANSITION IS COMPLETE. WE KNOW
THAT THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING FUND EXPERIENCES FALL
TO LEVELS OF EXPENDITURES AND
REVENUES. AND ANY INCREASED
COSTS TO THE FUND COULD
EXACERBATE A STRUCTURAL DEFICIT.
ON JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FOR
THE BILL WOULD ELIMINATE THE
FIND A AND MOST OF THE REVENUES
THAT ARE DEPOSITED INTO THIS
FUND WERE TRANSFERRED TO THE-
BEVERAGE CONTAINER STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION. INCLUDING
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS IN SIERRA B.
COLLECTIONS ANNUALLY. WE WOULD
NOTE THAT- THIS CALL MAY RESULT
IN SOME AMOUNT OF SAVINGS DUE
TO THE REDUCED ROLE FOR CAL
RECYCLE IN THE DAY TO DAY
OPERATIONS OF THE PROGRAM ONCE
THE TRANSITION TO THE
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION TAKES
PLACE HOWEVER. ANY SAVINGS
COULD PUT PRESSURE ON
INTEGRATED WASTE MANAGEMENT
ACCOUNT WHICH IS IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT TO FIND
POSITIONS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
FUNDED BY THE BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUND. THE
CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION CORPS
ESTIMATES A DECREASE OF
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. BEVERAGE
CONTAINER RECYCLING FUND
ANNUALLY BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE. FROM
AN INTERAGENCY AGREEMENT WITH
CAL RECYCLE TO ASSIST COMMUNITY
CONSERVATION CORPS. TO BECOME
CERTIFIED RECYCLING CENTERS.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD NOTE THE
CAL RECYCLE CURRENTLY PROVIDES
APPROXIMATELY NINE MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY IN GRANTS FROM
THE BCRF. TO COMMUNITY
CONSERVATION COURSE TO ASSIST
IN BEVERAGE CONTAINER.
CONTAINER COLLECTION AND LITTER
REDUCTION. AND IF THE
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION DOES
NOT MAINTAIN THIS GRANT PROGRAM.
THE CONSERVATION CORPS COULD
EXPERIENCE A SIGNIFICANT
DECREASE IN FUNDING BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE. FINALLY ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF TAX
AND FEE ADMINISTRATION THIS
BILL IS NOT EXPECTED TO RESULT
IN ANY DECREASE IN SALES AND
USE TAX REVENUE. ALTHOUGH THE
BILL WOULD CHANGE THE ENTITY.
THE CHARGES ZERO V. FROM CAL
RECYCLE TO THE STORAGE OF
ORGANIZATION. IT'S STILL BE
INCLUDED AS PART OF THE GROSS
RECEIPTS FOR THE CALCULATION OF
SALES AND USE TAX WHEN
APPLICABLE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WE'VE HEARD FROM FINANCE I SEE
NO HANDS GO UP SO WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THIRTY EIGHT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE WE WILL MOVE ON
SB THREE FORTY SIX ALSO BY
SENATOR WHITE COUNTY ON JAN
VEHICLES CAMERAS HE'S WAIVED
HIS PRESENTATION AND WE WILL GO
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT SAYING
NO ONE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
SAYING NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
QUEUE UP ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FORTY SIX. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE FOUR SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF
ONE OUT TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO NINE ONE. ONE HUNDRED AND
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO
RESPONSIBLE MOVEON AND AS A
REMINDER YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN THEY'RE ALL FOR SUPPORT OF
S. B. THREE FOUR SIX. WE HAVE
NOBODY IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME
MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT WHEN I
GOT OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
FORTY SIX AM BODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE SING NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE ON THE
LINE OPPOSED TO SB. THREE FORTY
SIX. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE FORTY SIX YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO OF THE OPPOSITION
OF SB. THREE FOUR SIX. AND WE
HAVE NO OPPOSITION YOU AT THIS
TIME OF YEAR. ALL RIGHT- WILL
COME TO FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE ON SB THREE FORTY
SIX. SEEING NONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE FORTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPEND. WILL MOVE
TO MISTER DALITS S. B. TWO OH
SEVEN ON PHOTOVOLTAIC RECYCLING
ADVISORY GROUPS- THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE IMAGE IT'S
ALWAYS WAY PRESENTATION. I WILL
GO TO SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE AND
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWO OH SEVEN. THANK YOU IF YOU
WERE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO OH
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO ONE OF THEIR
APPEARANCE THE PARTS OF S. B.
TWO OH SEVEN. WE HAVE NO
SUPPORT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE WILL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO OH
SEVEN I SEE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
FORTY TWO OH THREE I SEE NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MODERATOR
COULD QUEUE OF ANYONE ON THE
LINE OPPOSED S. B. TWO OH SEVEN.
IF YOU WERE ON OPPOSITION OF F.
B. TWO OH SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE HUNDRED
ZERO IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. YOUR. SEVEN AND WE HAVE
NO OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT- DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
S. B. TWO OH SEVEN SO WE'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
SAYING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION S. B. TWO OH SEVEN.
WILL MOVE TO THE SUSPENSE FILE
I'VE JUST BEEN INFORMED THAT DR
KIM IS NOW ON THE LINE WE HAD
OFFERED HIM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. IN OPPOSITION OF SB
EIGHTY TWO- DR KIM. IF YOU
COULD BE CONFINED YOURSELF TO A
MINUTE THAT WOULD BE GREAT.
BECAUSE WE'RE RUNNING LATE AND
WE'VE- GIVEN EVERY OPPORTUNITY
BUT WE HAD COMMITTED TO YOU SO
IF YOU'RE THERE PLEASE SPEAK ON
SB. EIGHTY TWO. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN. OKAY YEAH- YOU
KNOW AS A FORMER LIGHT
HEAVYWEIGHT BOXER UC BERKELEY I
UNDERSTAND A BUNCH CAN BE
DEVASTATING BUT THAT'S WHY WE
HAVE WEEK CLASSES YOU COULD
PICK UP ON YOUR OWN SITE.
HOWEVER ACADEMIC RESEARCH RIGHT
ROCK NINETY FOUR SHOWS
CRIMINALS CHOOSE VICTIMS WERE
WEAKER VULNERABLE AND ON ARTS
ADJUSTING OUR MOTHERS AND ALL.
I RESEARCH WHY CRIME INCREASE.
HOW WE SPEND INCREASES. AND
THEN CRIME GOES BACKED UP SO
YOU CAN PROVE YOUR QUESTION IF
ROBERT EVEN CREEK COME FIRST
CALIFORNIA'S. SPENDING WILL
INCREASE ONE POINT ONE BILLION
YEARLY WHICH STORES PROP FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU BYE AND-
INSERTED OF. AFTER PROPERTY
SEVEN BURGLARIES AND ROBBERIES
SKYROCKETED 8877% RESPECTIVELY-
WE INCREASE COOLEY SPENDING.
AND THEN CRIME NOT BACK DOWN-
SO WE ALSO VOTED AGAINST EXTRA
TAXES SO WHAT ENDED UP
HAPPENING IS NON LEAGUE CITY
WORKERS. ABOUT FIRED BUT
DEFENDERS WHAT THIS BUT FOR
THEIR OWN FELT. IGNORING
CRIMINOLOGY BEAUTIFIED OF
SUPPORTING RIMINAL AND
SUPPORTING HI NOT CHANGE DATA
CLIENT. MAKES A MOCKERY OF ALL
SCIENCE. BUT CRIME IS IN THE
HEART NOT THE COLOR OF THE SKIN
FATHERLESS HOUSEHOLDS EXPLAIN
MORE VARIATION OF OUTCOMES AND
REYES. THE POOR SINGLE MOM IS
THE TOUGHEST JOB IN THE WORLD-
IT'S NEVER OKAY TO HIT SOMEONE
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE ROBBING. A
PUBLIC SAFETY SHARED WONDERING
AT THE EIGHTY TWO IS LIKE
HIRING DAVID DUKE WHO NEED TO
END UP IN. AND DOUBLE ACP OR
BROCK TURNER TO LEAD THE
NATIONAL ORGANIZATION OF WOMEN
SB EIGHTY TO EXTEND WOMEN'S
TRAUMA BROUGHT HER SLAP ON THE
WRIST THE BATTERED WOMEN.
ELDERLY AND CHILDREN VIOLENTLY
ROBBED OF THEIR DIGNITY AND
SAFETY OF CRIMINALS REALLY NEED
TO THINK ON THEIR OWN SITES SO
PLEASE STAY NOTE THAT YOU NEED
TO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY THAT CONCLUDES THAT
CONCLUDES OUR TESTIMONY ON SB
EIGHTY TWO. WILL MOVE TO S. B.
TEN BY MISTER WINNER ON
AUTOMATED LICENSE PLATES. THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATA MISTER
WINNER HAS WAY PRESENTATION FOR
ANYONE HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
TWO TENSING NOBODY IN THIS
ROOM. SAYING NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY SAYING NO ONE.
SHOULD MAY WILL GO TO THE PHONE.
LINE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
S. B. TEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT
THEN ZERO NOW. IN SUPPORT OF AB
B. TWO TEN. THE RECORDED LINE
OF THIRTEEN YEAR LINE OF OPEN.
BY ONE THIRD AIRLINER OPEN.
HELLO YOUR OWN. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
TEN THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY- MODERATOR
FEATURED QUEUE UP THE
OPPOSITION. TO S. B. TWO TEN
NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY. THANK
YOU. IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO TEN ONE
AND THEN. ZERO WE DO HAVE ONE
IN Q. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
AGAIN EDITED ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR ANY OPPOSITION UP TO TEN.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DOT
LEVEL- I. YEAH NOT THIS THAT
THE WELL- BUT- ALL RIGHT WELL
ALL RIGHT WE CAN HEAR YOU SEE
AND IF YOU COULD JUST YOUR NAME
AND YOUR. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
SPEAKER. AND WE HAV NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. ALL RIGHT TO PARTMINER
FINANCES NOT HAVE A FILE ON S.
B. TWO TEN WILL COME BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE SEEING NO HANDS
GO UP. WITHOUT OBJECTION S. B.
TWO TEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON AT TWO FORTY THREE.
BY WEST WINNER ON TRIAL
TESTIMONY EXPERT WITNESSES. THE
AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. IS
THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT THIS IS
OUR OPPORTUNITY SEEING NOBODY
IN ROOM FORTY TWO A THREE THING
NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT. OF SB TWO FORTY THREE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
S. B. TWO FORTY THREE MY PRESS
ONE AND. ZERO ONE ZERO FOR ANY
SUPPORT. YEAH MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE NO ONE IN SUPPORT AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
OPPOSITION PRESS TWO TO FORTY
THREE SEEN NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSING OVER THE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOW IS THE
OPPORTUNITY MODERATED A Q. OF
THE OPPOSITION TO SB TWO FORTY
THREE. SIX THANK YOU HAVE BEEN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FORTY
THREE MY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO FORTY
THREE. AND WE HAVE NOTICED
OPPOSITION AND YOU AT THE TIME
ALL RIGHT WE'LL COME BACK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE IN SB TWO FORTY
THREE SEEING MY COLLEAGUES WITH
THEIR HANDS DOWN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB TWO FORTY THREE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. WE WILL
MOVE DESK BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN BY
MISTER WIENER ON GENERAL PLAN
ANNUAL REPORTS THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MISTER
WINNER IS WAY PRESENTATIONS OR
ANYONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE IN SUPPORT. OF SB FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN SEEING NINE. SIGNOS
SUPPORT IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB. FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN SEVEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN THEY'RE OFF YOUR
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN. AND WE WERE GONNA LINE
OF ONE TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING THIS IS JUST
NOT ABOUT LEADERSHIP GROUP AND
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. RIGHT THANK
YOU. AND WE WILL BOTTOM LINE OF
ONE NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BOTH YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REPORT
ONE NINETEEN AIRLINE OF THE
OPEN WE CAN HEAR YOU. HELLO
YOU'RE A LITTLE LOW. ABU WHAT
ABOUT THE TOPIC. ALL THANK YOU.
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q.
ALL RIGHT WHEN I GOT OPPOSITION
OF SB FOUR SEVEN SEVENTEEN NO
ONE IN THIS ROOM THING NO ONE
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY OUR
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE IN OPPOSITION THAT'S
BEFORE SEVEN SEVEN. THANK YOU
IF YOU'RE IN OPPOSITION- SB
FORTY SEVEN SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OF SB
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE OF THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS SPEAKING ON MY
OWN BEHALF IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU ANNEX OF THE LINE OF
FOURTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
FOLLOWING ARE BORN RESIDENT OF
REDONDO BEACH AND A MEMBER OF
THE UNITED NEIGHBORS I OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. AND THAT
IS ONE AND THEN ZERO IN
OPPOSITION OF SB. FOUR SEVEN
SEVEN. AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM BOTH SUPPORT AND OPPOSE WE
WILL GO TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE. MY COLLEAGUES HAVE THEIR
HANDS DOWN SO THAT UP TO FIVE
PHYSICIAN WITHOUT OBJECTION SP
FOUR SEVEN SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO SENATOR
LEYVA PUBLIC POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
FOSTER YOUTH. THE AUTHORS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE WILL MOVE RIGHT
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY ROOM FORTY TWO
OR THREE. IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
OH TWO TWO EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO TWO EIGHT NOW IS OUR
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU HAVE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
TWO EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN THEY'RE
OFF YOUR SUPPORT OF SB. TWO TWO
EIGHT. MISTER CHAIR THERE ARE
NO WILL NO SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ABOUT
OPPOSITION IF ANYBODY SUPPOSED
S. B. TWO TO EIGHT HOURS ARE
OPPORTUNITY SINGLE BUT IN THIS
ROOM. SCENE OF AN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY TWENTY ONE ON THE
LINE OPPOSED SB TWO TWO EIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR OPPOSITION OF SB
TWO TO EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF SB. TWO
TWO EIGHT. AND ONE MOMENT WE TO
HAVE ONE PERSON IN Q. THANK YOU
FOR PATIENTLY WAITING WE WILL
GO TO LINE UP ON. ONE THIRTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO NINE
ONE THIRTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO NOTE AT THE EIGHTY TWO.
OKAY THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER- NO FURTHER QUEUE ALL
RIGHT THAT WAS OPPOSITION
CORRECT. ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW
COME BACK TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE IN A SPEECH TO WAIT. MANY
MEMBERS AND NOT HAVE THEIR
HANDS UP WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWO TWO EIGHT IS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE. PULLING THAT'S
B. TWO FORTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
BATES ON SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS- MISSTATES HIS WAY
PRESENTATION AND WE WILL THIS
IS SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO
RIGHT TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
FOR ANYONE HERE IN TWO FOUR
EIGHT TWO MILLION FORTY TWO OH
THREE AND SUPPORT SEEING NONE
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB.
TWO FOUR EIGHT. HE WENT A PART
OF. SB. TWO FOUR EIGHT. ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
BERGENLINE OF ONE NINETEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN AREAS YES SIR-
JOHN LEVEL ON BEHALF OF THE-
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB. TWO FOUR EIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWO FOUR EIGHT IT IS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'LL GO TO
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO FOUR
EIGHT. SEEING NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM OPPOSED SB TWO FOUR
EIGHTEEN NO ONE IN. FROM TWENTY
FORTY THIRTY ONE ON THE PHONE
LINE POST SB TWO FOUR EIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR IN
OPPOSITION- SB TWO FOUR EIGHT
IN MY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO FOUR
EIGHT. WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER.
ALL RIGHT HAVING HEARD FROM
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WE WILL GO
TO DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WHICH
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE. SEEING NO
HANDS OF MY COLLEAGUES GO UP
WITHOUT OPPOSITION FIFTY TWO
FOUR EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO. A SENATOR HERTZBERG
THREE BILLS HIS WAY
PRESENTATION SB TWO SIX TO
UNVEIL IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
WILL GO TO SUPPORT- THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE IN
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
MODERATOR. IS THERE ANYONE. IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO SIX TWO ON
THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO
SIX TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO WE WILL GO TO THE
LINE A ONE OH FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORE MATURE MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORED POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY WILL PROBABLY
BE A SPONSOR AND ALSO. REGISTRY
IN SUPPORT OF A CO SPONSOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA'S RESPECT
INSTRUCTORS THEM ANTI RIVER
RECIDIVISM COALITION THANK YOU.
HE. AND IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TWO SIX TWO YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
ARE GOING TO GO TO THE
OPPOSITION I KNOW WE HAVE ONE
PRIMARY WITNESS- A RYAN COUSINS
HIS ASSISTANT CHIEF DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY OF YOLO
COUNTY. MR COUSINS YOU HAVE
THREE MINUTES PLEASE- TELL US
YOUR POSITION. GOOD MORNING
DISTINGUISHED PANEL. THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF S. B. TWO SIXTY TWO
COMES FROM THE FACT. BUT IT
TAKES DISCRETION AWAY FROM
JUDGES TO POTENTIALLY SET A
DIFFERENT BILL IF THERE'S A
SAFETY RISK OR A FLIGHT RISK
THE AMENDMENTS TO THE PENAL
CODE SECTION TWELVE SIXTY NINE
BE. SAY IF A CRIME IS NOT ON
THE LIST IT'S ZERO BAIL THIS
ACTUALLY CREATES A ZERO BAIL
LOOPHOLE BECAUSE IF YOUR CRIME
IS NOT ON THE LIST. WHICH IS
FINE IF YOU YOU'RE GIVEN THAT
CHANCE TO SHOW UP IF YOU DON'T
SHOW UP A WARRANT IS ISSUED. IN
THE AMOUNT OF ZERO BAIL AGAIN
EVEN A FAILURE TO APPEAR IS
ZERO BAIL. SO THEORETICALLY
PEOPLE WOULD BE STUCK IN A
LOOPHOLE WHERE IF THEIR CRIME
IS ON THE LIST. THEY COULD
NEVER SHOW UP FOR COURT. THE IF
THIS CAUSES EVEN A 10% INCREASE
IN FAILURES TO APPEAR. THIS
WOULD COST AT A MARGINAL áP
MARGINAL COST FOR THE POLICE
RESPONSE TO ADDRESSING FTAS
WOULD BE. IN MY OPINION A
MINIMUM ONE POINT THREE TWO TWO
TOTAL ANNUALLY- BUT THE GREATER
RISK COMES FROM THE CRIMES THAT
WOULD BE COMMITTED WHILE PEOPLE
ARE OUT ON ZERO BAIL WE HAD A
CHANCE TO SEE THIS DURING KOBE-
IN YOLO COUNTY WHERE PRACTICE
WE HAD OVER EIGHT HUNDRED.
CRIMES COMMITTED BY PEOPLE
RELEASED ON ZERO BAIL IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ZERO BILL EMERGENCY
SCHEDULES COUNTY TO COUNTY I
DID NOT LOOK AT ALL OF THEM BUT
I TOOK A CROSS SECTION. THEY
MORE OR LESS MIRROR THE CRIME
LIST OF THIS BILL- BUT IN EVEN
A SMALL COUNTY REPRESENTING ONE
HALF OF 1% OF THE POPULATION
THAT WAS OVER EIGHT HUNDRED
CRIMES 43% SAN FRANCISCO SIMILE
34% OF THE PEOPLE THAT THEY
RELEASED ON ZERO BAIL- WERE RE
ARRESTED THAT THEY ONLY HAD
ZERO BAIL FOR A TWO MONTH
PERIOD. SO WITH THIS
EXTRAPOLATED IS THAT THE
MARGINAL COST TO RESPOND TO
PROPERTY CRIMES TWELVE HUNDRED
NINETY FOUR DOLLARS VIOLENT
CRIMES TEN THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THIS WOULD
EXTRAPOLATE TO AN ADDITIONAL
TWO HUNDRED FIFTEEN MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL ANNUAL COSTS
MARGINALLY FOR THE POLICE
RESPONSE- AND THEN THAT'S ONLY
IF EVERY NEW CRIME WAS A
PROPERTY CRIME WHICH YOU
WOULDN'T BE. IF YOU DIVIDED
THAT BETWEEN PROPERTY CRIME AND
VIOLENT CRIME THE MARGINAL COST
INCREASE WOULD BE ONE POINT
ZERO ONE BILLION FOR POLICE
RESPONSE TO THESE NEW CRIMES.
AND THEN USING CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS OF CRIME BOARD
STATISTICS IF ONLY 10% OF THE
NEW CRIMES COMMITTED BY THOSE
ON ZERO BAIL INVOLVED VICTIMS
WHO APPLIED FOR RELIEF. JUST
10% THERE'D BE AN ADDITIONAL
COST OF TWENTY ONE POINT FOUR
EIGHT MILLION ANNUALLY SO AGAIN
THE PROBLEM IS THIS ZERO BAIL
LOOPHOLE THAT'S RELEASED THE
JUDGES WOULD BE POWERLESS. TO
TAKE SOMEBODY WHO IS EVEN A
FLIGHT RISK OR A SECURITY RISK
AND SET A DIFFERENT KIND OF
BAIL UNDER THIS SCHEDULE WHICH
HAS SOME SERIOUS CRIMES ASSAULT
WITH FORCE LIKELY TO CAUSE
GREAT BODILY INJURY EVEN IF IT
IS A HATE CRIME IS ZERO BAIL.
UNDER THIS SCHEDULE. I CAN
ANSWER ANY. ROM THE COMMITTEE
ON HOW I REACHED- MY NUMBERS.
THANK YOU SIR FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY APPRECIATED THANK YOU
YOU KNOW HANDS GO UP WILL NOW
GO TO OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THIS ROOM. OPPOSE THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE OPPOSED S. B. TWO SIX TWO.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN THEREOF IN OPPOSITION-
S. B. TWO SIX TWO. AND WE HAVE
NOT BEEN WE HAVE ONE Q. AND UP
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. BETTER CLIMB
FROM LINE OF ONE OH NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YES HI I'M MY
NAME NAMES ALEX LAM
REPRESENTING MYSELF AND THAT.
I'M ACCORDING TO THE- THANK YOU
STRONGLY. THANK. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT HAVING HEARD
FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION WILL GO
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WHICH IS NOT HAVE A FILING S.
B. TWO SIX TO COME BACK THE
COMMITTEE NO HANDS HAVE GONE UP
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO SIX
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
TO OUR NEXT ITEM S. B. THREE
FOUR FOUR I MISSED HERTZBERG ON
HOMELESS SHELTERS AND GRANTS-
AND PETS AND VETERINARY
SERVICES IT'S A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE MISTER HERTZBERG IS
WAY PRESENTATION. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE WE DO HAVE TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT IN THIS ROOM WHICH WE
WILL START WITH. MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHTS IN NO ONE ELSE COME TO
THE MICROPHONE MOVED TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY THERE'S NO ONE
THERE MODERATORS OR ANYONE ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FOUR FOUR. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE FOUR
FOUR YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. WE WILL GO ONLINE OF
NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BY NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YOU HAVE A SIMILAR. THE NEXT
LINE WILL GO TO IS NINE FIFTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS IS JENNIFER APPEARING ON
BEHALF OF THE BEST FRIENDS
ANIMAL SOCIETY SAN DIEGO HUMANE
SOCIETY. AND SAN FRANCISCO SPCA
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATOR HERTZBERG SB THREE
FORTY FOUR PROGRAM IS A KEY
PART OF STATE AND LOCAL
STRATEGY TO BRING OUR IN HOUSE
NEIGHBORS. INTO HOUSING AND
INTO SERVICES AND ME STRONGLY
SUPPORT CODIFYING THE PROGRAM
AND FUNDING TO SUPPORT IT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF
ONE THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT YOU CAN BANKS WITH THE LF
PPL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FORTY FOUR. WITH NEWS
YEAR'S TEAM- HOUSING ARE
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. A REMINDER THIS ONE AND
THEN THE SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE
FOUR FOUR. AND WE WILL GO TO
THE NECKLINE OF THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN BROKEN
COALITION FOR SAN FRANCISCO
NEIGHBORHOODS SPEAKING ON MY
OWN BEHALF IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT REMOVED COMPOSITION OF SB
THREE FOUR FORCING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM. IN ALLEN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR PLEASE
QUEUE UP ANYONE OPPOSED SB
THREE FOUR FOUR. THANK YOU FAN
OPPOSITION UP SB THREE FOUR BAR
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION
OF SB. THREE FOUR FOUR. AND WE
HAVE AN OPPOSITION QUEUE AT
THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR- I
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM SUPPORT NOT
THE DAY AFTER THE PROPOSITION
WILL MOVE TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE. ON MY COMMITTEE
COLLEAGUES HAVE THEIR HANDS UP
SO WITHOUT OBJECTION SB THREE
FOUR FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
SB FOUR FIFTY FIVE RESEARCH
BURKE ON FIRE DISTRICT FUNDING-
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
HE'S PLAY PRESENTATION WILL GO
RIGHT INTO SUPPORT IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN SUPPORT NOW SURE
OPPORTUNITY THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE. HERE TO
TESTIFY THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY FIGHTERS OR ANYONE
ON THE LINE. IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR FIFTY. THANK YOU YOUR
SUPPORT OF SB PORT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN. ZERO ONE
AND THEN ZERO FJORD IN SUPPORT
OF SB. FOUR FIFTY. MISTER CHAIR
THERE ARE NO SUPPORT IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
FIFTY THREE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
SCENE ALLEN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY LETTERS OR ANYONE ON THE
LINE OPPOSED S. B. FOUR FIFTY.
THIS INCIDENT THANK YOU HAVE
BEEN OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR
FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN. ZERO ONE AND THEN ZERO OF
YOUR IN OPPOSITION SB. FOUR
FIFTY. AND WE HAVE NO ONE IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME MISTER
GENERATE HAVING OFF THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR TESTIMONY WE
WILL GO TO DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A
FILE MY COLLEAGUES TO NOT HAVE
THEIR HANDS UP. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB FOUR FIFTY WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO SENATOR
NEWMAN THREE BILLS HE IS WAY
PRESENTATION THE FIRST ONE IS
S. B. TWO SIX SIX ON THE CHINO
HILLS STATE PARK EXPANSION-
PLEASE GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
THERE'S NOBODY IN THIS ROOM
THERE'S NO ONE IN TWENTY FORTY
MODERATOR. THERE ANYONE WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB. TWO
SIX SIX ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
IF YOU AREN'T. OF S. B. TWO SIX
SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN.
ZERO ONE AND THEN ZERO APPEARED
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO SIX SIX.
WE DO HAVE ONE THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT IN THE FUTURE. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE A ONE THIRTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS
MELANIE SLAUGHTER BACK BILL
SPONSORED BILLS FOR EVERYONE WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE BALLOT
THANK YOU. THEN WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT BUT OPPOSITION
FIRST B. TWO SIX SIX THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED
THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. BINDERS OR ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED S. B. TWO
SIX SIX. THANK YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SIX THANK
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
ONE AND THEN THERE ARE A FEW IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO SIX SIX.
WE DO HAVE ONE IN HERE ONE
MOMENT HERE. AND THAT'LL COME
FROM LINE OF ONE FORTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. YEAH I UPLOAD. IT
THANK YOU. WE'RE NOT ON THERE
ON SB TWO SIX SIX APPEAR IN
OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT
THE TIME IT'S YOUR TURN OR ALL
RIGHT WE'VE HEARD FROM SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION OF HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY BERMAN FINANCED IS
NOT HAVE A FILING S. B. TWO SIX
SIX. COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
TWO SIX SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
WILL MOVE ON TO SB THREE SIXTY
TO FIND COMMUNITY PHARMACIES-
THE AUTHORS WAY PRESENTATION
AND WE'LL GO RIGHT IT'S A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE WILL GO
RIGHT TO. TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE SIX TWO. SEE NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM SAYING NO ONE IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY FIGHTERS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX TWO.
THANK YOU FOR IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE SIX TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE SIX TWO. AND WE WON'T
GO TO THE LINE OF ONE FORTY
FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS GOT ON
BEHALF OF UNITED NURSES
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA YOU
THAT- IN SUPPORT OF IT. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE HAVE NOT
FOR THE SUPPORT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION SB THREE SIX TWO.
NOW TRAP TRINITY THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED TO THREE
SIX TWO THERE'S NOBODY IN
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED. FOR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED TO SP THREE SIX TWO.
THANK YOU IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE SIXTY MY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE CLEAR UP IN
OPPOSITION OF S. B. THREE SIX
TWO. AND WE HAVE NO OPPOSITION
IN Q. ALL RIGHT HAVE AN OFFER
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BOTH
SUPPORT OPPOSED POSITIONS WE
WILL MOVE FARTHER TO FINANCE
WHICH DOES NOT HAVE A FILE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION SB
THREE SIX TO. GO TO SUSPENSE
BERMAN S. B. SIX SIX ONE ON
VETERANS FARMING HOME LOAN
PROGRAM. THE AUTHOR HAS WAY
PRESENTATION THE SUSPENSE
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE MOVED TO
SUPPORT THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY FIVE
WRITERS OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX SIX
ONE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
SB SIX SIX ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF
SB. SIX ONE. AND ONE MOMENT FOR
OUR FIRST ONE IN Q. AND THAT'LL
COME FROM LINE OF ONE TWENTY
FOUR. RIGHT ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. IT'S MY TURN YES
I HAD- I JUST A STRONGLY
OPPOSED THE IT BE EIGHTY TWO R.
I. WERE NOT ON SB EIGHTY TWO.
ANYBODY'S ON THE QUEUE THAT
WANTS TO SPEAK ON SB EIGHTY TWO
THAT AS WITH LONG LONG PAST US.
SB SIX SIX ONE. WE WERE WAITING
FOR TESTIMONY ON SB. SIX SIX
ONE SEVEN. SO IF YOU AREN'T A
PART OF SB SIX SIX ONE YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. AND WE
HAVE NO SUPPORT YOU AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA DO OPPOSE POSITION
ON SB SIX SIX ONE THERE'S
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM OPPOSE. IT
OF ANY ROOM TWENTY FORTY IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SB. SIX SIX ONE. IF YOU
ARE AN OPPOSITION OF SB. SIX
SIX ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO
FOR ANY OPPOSITION S. B. SIX
ONE. WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO I'M STRONGLY OPPOSED THE
BILL S. B. SB TWO IT'S CRAZY
THANK YOU. MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD TELL PEOPLE THAT SB
EIGHTY TWO IS LONG PAST US WERE
NOW ON OPPOSITION OF SB. SIX
SIX ONE. WHERE IN OPPOSITION OF
S. B. SIX SIX ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO FOUR SB. SIX
SIX ONE. THE CUSTOMER OF THE
KING OF JORDAN AND WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS
TIME MISTER CHAIR ALL RIGHT AND
WE HAVE NO FILE FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND I
HAVE NO HANDS UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB SIX SIX ONE. WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE MISTER JONES YOU
CAN PRESENT SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT
WHICH IS A TO PASS
RECOMMENDATION YOU CAN DO RIGHT
FROM YOUR SEAT. AND WE WILL
TELL RIGHT TO S. B. TWO EIGHT
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN CALLING SENATE BILL S.
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY EIGHT
ESTABLISHES A SINGLE STEP
CONVERSION PROCESS FOR
CALIFORNIA CORPORATIONS TO
BECOME FOREIGN CORPORATIONS.
ALL HAS MINOR OBSERVABLE COSTS
AND IS EXPECTED TO RESULT IN
MINOR REVENUE INCREASES FROM
ADDITIONAL FILINGS I HAVE
DERREN NONE ON THE LINE FROM
THE CORPORATIONS COMMITTEE OF
THE BUSINESS LAW SECTION. OF
THE CALIFORNIA LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION THE SPONSOR OF THE
MEASURE. ALL RIGHT MR NINE WE
WILL HEAR FROM YOU AS OUR
PRIMARY WITNESS. TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND.
LEGISLATION THE OPERATION'S
COMMITTEE OF THE BUSINESS LAW
SECTION OF THE CALIFORNIA
LAWYERS ASSOCIATION TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHT
EIGHT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU WE
HAVE HEARD FROM YOUR PRIMARY
WITNESS THERE'S NO ONE ELSE IN
THIS ROOM IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
EIGHT EIGHT THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT.
FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB TWO EIGHT EIGHT YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU AREN'T
SUPPORT OF SB. TWO EIGHT EIGHT.
AND WE HAVE NO SUPPORT QUEUE AT
THIS TIME THE FUTURE ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING OPPOSITION FOR SB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT I SEE NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSED I SEE NO ONE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. TWENTY ONE
ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSED SB
TWO EIGHT EIGHT. THANK YOU AND
HAVE APPEARED OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWO EIGHT EIGHT. YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. YOUR
CALL ONE AND THEN VEER OFF YOUR
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
EIGHT EIGHT. AND WE HAD WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME MISTER CHAIR
ALL RIGHTS BERMAN FINANCED IS
NOT HAVE A FILE ON SD TWO EIGHT
EIGHT. MISTER JONES WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND I WOULD ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE PLEASE. ALL RIGHT WE-
HAVE A CLOSE I SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS. SIR MOTION THE TO DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION ALMOST.
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
BRADFORD- MR SECRETARY WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AS-
YOU EIGHT EIGHT. THE BILL TWO
EIGHT EIGHT- THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO AYE PORTANTINO BY
BATES. BRADFORD BRADFORD BY
JONES I'VE JONES HI COM LOGGER
I AM LONGER BY LAYERED. LAYERED
BY WHAT KASKY HI CASKEY FIVE
SIX BUCKS WE WILL KEEP THAT
OPEN FROM IS BATES AND THAT
BILL WILL BE OUT- WILL GO ON SB
TWO NINETY SIX. I MISS MONTH
MISS LIMóN ON CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS AND SHE IS WAY
PRESENTATION AND THIS IS A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE. WILL DIRECT
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
THERE'S NOBODY IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE THERE'S NOBODY ON.
IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATOR
IF YOU COULD- PROMPT FOLKS ON
THE LINE IN SUPPORT. OF SB TWO
NINETY SIX. THANK YOU FOR IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. TWO NINE SIX
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. ONE AND THEN ZERO FOR ANY
SUPPORT BUT IN SB. TWO NINE
SIX. AND WE WILL GO TO A LINE
OF THIRTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING- MY NAME
IS OFFICER RUBEN HERNANDEZ THE
NEW SENATE COLLISION COURSE
RIGHT. AND SENATE BILL NINETY
SIX SHOULD NOT BE IT. ALL THE-
SUSPENSE CALENDAR IT SHOULD BE
PASSED THROUGH A- SENATE FLOOR
UNDER RULE TWENTY EIGHT POINT
EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO A LOT OF TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. DERRELL RIVERA
THE PRESIDENT A CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS CALLING IN SUPPORT OF
SB TWO NINETY SIX. THIS IS A
THIS IS NO SPECIFIC BECAUSE
BILL THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
PASSED UNDER THANK YOU TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY TAKING. NAME
AFFILIATION AND YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AN EXTRA
LINE OF TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS DAVID SPEARS I'M ACCORDING
PORTION OFFICER FOR THE CITY OF
CARSON AND I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. OUR SAFETY
MATTERS. THANK YOU NXR THE
LIGHT OF ONE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THIS HI MY NAME
IS JAMIE DOLLAR MAKOTO OFFICER
AT THE CITY OF POWAY AND ON THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS THE MORE
MATURE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY SIX SHOULD NOT
BE ON THE SUSPENSE GALLAGHER
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN PASSED
THANK YOU FOR THE SENATE
FLORIDA RULE THANK YOU ANNIE
THANK YOUNG WE'RE TAKING JUST
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF. ONE
TWENTY TWO. AND KIRKLAND HOP
THE COMPANY A CONFESSION
OFFICERS SENATE BILL TWO NINETY
SIX BEING CALENDAR IT SHOULD BE
PASSED THIS ON THE EIGHTY
TWENTY POINT EIGHT. THANK YOU
NEXT A LINE OF ONE FORTY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WELL LARRY
BROOKS ALAMEDA COUNTY HEALTHY
HOMES DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE OF ONE NINETEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THANK
YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YES JOHN
LEVEL WITH THE CODE ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS. DOES A TWENTY EIGHT
POINT EIGHT CANDIDATES
SHOULDN'T BE AN EXPENSE THANK
YOU. MEXICO LINE OF EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. REMOTE VIDEO
SACRAMENTO PRO DIVISION
ALTHOUGH CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
CODE ENFORCEMENT CALLING IN
SUPPORT OF IT YOU TO NINETY SIX
OUR SAFETY MATTERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL GOT A LINE OF ONE
TWENTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
YEAH THIS IS- DAHLE LOCAL CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS DALY CITY.
AND I'M ALSO A MEMBER CASE FEEL
STRONGLY REQUESTING THAT SENATE
DR NINETY SIX NOT BEING SPENT
CALENDAR IT SHOULD NOT. THANK
YOU FOR TAKING OF FOR. AND
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT A LOT OF ONE FORTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ED PLAQUES RETIRED- COULDN'T
FORSMAN DIAMOND BAR. AND SENATE
BILL TWO NINETY SIX SHOULD NOT
BE ON SUSPENSE CALENDAR IT
SHOULD HAVE BEEN PASSED THANK
YOU. FOR YOUR. THANK YOU NEXT
OF A LINE OF FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS ALAN I'M THE PRESIDENT
OF CONGRESS CONGRESS ALREADY
QUALITY. THAT THE INTERNATIONAL
BANK PUBLISHING DENTISTRY
SUPPORT OF THE BILL BUT. THANK
YOU ANEXO GO OF ONE FORTY NINE
YEAR LINE OF THE- BUT- I. JEAN
MAY HAVE- CALLED. TO OPPOSE THE
SB EIGHTY TWO ARE WE'RE NOT ON
THAT BILL NOW THANK YOU NEXT
SPEAKER. OKAY WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORTING QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE WILL
NEVER OPPOSITION OF SB TWO
NINETY SIX THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM DESSERT KNOWN IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE. IN
OPPOSITION SB TWO NINETY SIX.
IN OPPOSITION OF S. B. TWO
NINETY SIX YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR ANY OPPOSITION OF S.
B. TWO NINETY SIX. I WILL GO TO
LINE OF FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE FIFTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. YES OKAY ONE MOMENT
HERE. I CAN HEAR YOU. ONE SIX
GO AHEAD. STAY IN NAME PLEASE.
YES L. HOLDS REGION TO BOARD
MEMBER FOR CACIO I'M IN URGENT
SUPPORTERS TO NINETY SIX FOR MY
FELLOW OFFICERS SIXTY THANK YOU.
AND IF YOU'RE AN OPPOSITION OF
SB TWO NINETY SIX YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. BORDERLINE A.
ONE FORTY NINE. THEY REALLY WE
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB TWO NINETY SIX
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DOES NOT
HAVE A FILE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
DO NOT HAVE THEIR HANDS UP SO
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB TWO NINETY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON SB THREE THREE ZERO. FIVE
SENATOR DORADO ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THIS IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE
MISTER ROGER WAS WAY
PRESENTATION- WILL GO TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AT SUPPORT I SEE
SOMEONE COMING UP IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THREE THREE ZERO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. ALL
RIGHTS IN NO ONE ELSE IN THIS
ROOM SAY KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY MODERATORS OR ANYONE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE THREE ZERO
ON THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE THREE ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE THREE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOOD
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
ZERO THREE NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
SEEN NOBODY IN TWENTY FORTY.
MODERATORS OR ANYONE. OPPOSED
SB THREE THREE ZERO ON THE
PHONE LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
SB THREE THREE ZERO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE THREE
ZERO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT WE
OFFER THE SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION OPPORTUNITY.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT OF
A FILE SIGNAL HANDS GIVE A GO
UP WITHOUT. OBJECTION SB THREE
THREE ZERO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE.
MOVING TO MR BECKER'S. TWO
BILLS HE'S WAY PRESENTATION
FIRST PRIZE SB THREE FORTY
FIVE. ON ENERGY PROGRAMS AND
PROJECTS NON ENERGY BENEFITS.
THIS IS A SUSPENDED CANDIDATE-
TAKING SUPPORT. C. NOBODY COME
TO THE MICROPHONE IN THIS ROOM
IN SUPPORT MOVING TO TWENTY
FORTY THERE'S NO ONE THERE
BOUNDARIES ARE ANYONE ONLINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
FOR SUPPORT FOR S. B. THREE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOOD OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE FORTY FIVE THERE'S NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSED THERE'S NO
ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY. MINOR
IS THERE ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB. THREE FORTY
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
FOR OPPOSITION OF S. B. THREE
FOUR FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HELLO TO
LIVE NINETY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GET MONEY OUT OF MY LOOK
WITH THAT NUMBER ENERGY
UTILITIES AND OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER LINES INTO AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT WE'VE TAKEN SUPPORT
IN OPPOSITION BERMAN FINANCES
NOT HAVE A FILING SB THREE
FORTY FIVE MANY MEMBERS DO NOT
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION. SB THREE FORTY FIVE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE. SB THREE
FIFTY FIVE AND COURT FEES. AND
COSTS WAIVERS- THIS AUTHORS WAY
FOR EXHORTATION IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. IS THERE ANYONE IN
SUPPORT IN ROOM FORTY TWO-
THREE NOW IS THE OPPORTUNITY
SEEING NO ONE THERE SEE NO ONE
IN TWENTY FORTY. MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ON THE LINE OPPOSE IT
SHOULD BE SUPPORTING SB THREE
FIVE FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF SB THREE
FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO
HAVE ONE NINE IN KYOTO JUST BE
ONE MOMENT. BEHIND ONE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NINE.
SEVEN KALAKAUA BONTA. THREE
FIFTY FIVE EIGHTY FOUR. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME RIGHT
REMOVED OPPOSITION OF SB THREE
FIFTY FIVE SEEING NO ONE IN
THIS ROOM WANTING TO OPPOSE IT
SING KNOWN IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SIR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB THREE FIVE
FIVE. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB THREE
FIVE FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
FOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING UP
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIVE
FIVE. BERMAN FINANCES NOT HAVE
A FILE BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE FIVE FIVE
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE. MOVING TO
MISTER WELCH TO BILLS- I HOPE
WE ARE REACHING OUT TO HIM.
HE'S PRESENTING A SECOND ONE
THE FIRST ONE SB THREE SIXTY IS
A SUSPECT CANDIDATE. STOP IT
FIRST WHAT IS A SUSPENSE
KENNEDY'S WAY PRESENTATION. WE
WILL TAKE A SUPPORT FOR SB
THREE SIXTY WHICH IS A CONSUMER
CREDIT REPORTING AGENCIES- SEE
NO ONE IN THIS ROOM SIGNAL IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY. IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB. THREE SIXTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIX ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT OF SB THREE SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION SB
THREE SIXTY THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM THERE SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FORTY. MISTER MARK
MODERATOR IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB. THREE SIXTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT
THIS TIME. FOR OPPOSITION OF SB
THREE SIXTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I BELIEVE
THAT. IS NOT HAVE A FILE AND
THERE ARE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SB THREE SIXTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE WILL NOW MOVE ON
SB FIVE TWENTY BY SENATOR
WELCOME. PLEASE COME UP AND
PRESENT THIS IS A ITEM ELIGIBLE
FOR DO PASS MOTION WELCOME
SENATOR WILL TELL US ABOUT SB
FIVE TWENTY THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS FROM HERE
TO PRESENT HAS YOU SAID SB FIVE
TWENTY WHICH WILL RE OPEN THE
PUBLIC PROTEST PERIOD ON STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD
WATER. APPLICATION
APPROPRIATION APPLICATIONS FOR
MINING USE WHEN THE DECISION
HAS BEEN MADE WITHIN THIRTY
YEARS FROM THE APPLICATION'S
ORIGINAL FILING DATE PRIOR TO A
FINAL DETERMINATION BEING MADE.
INCLUDES AN EXEMPTION NOT TO RE
OPEN THE WHOLE PROCESS THE
BOARD HOLDS A HEARING OR
CONDUCTS PROCEEDINGS AFTER
FORTY FIVE DAYS OF WRITTEN
NOTICE. THIS BILL OUT OF
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FORMALLY WAY IN
THAT PERFECT PRESENT EVIDENCE
BEFORE THE BOARD MAKES A FINAL
DETERMINATION. BY A LOCAL ISSUE
AFFECTING SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY ONE IS A PROPOSED MAKE
MY PROJECT AND SOLEDAD CANYON
THE WATER PREPARATION
APPLICATION WAS FILED IN
NINETEEN NINETY ONE THE STATE
WATER BOARD WITH NO HEARING
BEING HELD. AS DYNAMICS OF
WATER AVAILABILITY HAVE CHANGED
SIGNIFICANTLY FOR THE STATE. AS
A WHOLE DURING THE PAST THREE
DECADES. IT WITH- THE LAST
SCENIC WORLD RIVER INSIDE CAL.
AT THE FOOTSTEPS OF THIS
PROJECT SUCH ACTION WILL ALLOW
COMMUNITY MEMBERS OPPORTUNITY
TO PROVIDE CURRENT HYDROLOGICAL
DATA TO THE BOARD. HAS TO THE
IMPACT OF SUCH SHOP PROJECTS IN
THEIR LOCAL WATER SUPPLY. THIS
WILL HELP PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND ENSURE THAT THE
APPLICANTS APPROPRIATIONS ARE
INDEED IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
MEMBERS IS BILL PASSED ON THE
POLICY COMMITTEE WITH A
UNANIMOUS VOTE AND AS A MENTION
IN THE ANALYSIS THE COST OF
THIS BILL ARE MINOR IN
OBSERVABLE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR WELL. THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THIS
ROOM THERE'S NO ONE IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. BATTERIES OR
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FIVE TWENTY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWO ZERO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME I WILL GO TO OPPOSITION
THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS ROOM
OPPOSED ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY NO BOUNDARIES OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE AT THE POST
SB FIVE TWENTY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FIVE TWENTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN FOR OPPOSITION OF SB
FIVE TWENTY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OVER TO LINE FORTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
SCOTT GOVERNOR BEHALF OF AN-
SELECTED BAKER STAFF FOR THE
THOROUGH ANALYSIS. YEAH THE
PROJECT IN QUESTION IS
SPECULATIVE BUT THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED- WITH NOT BUILDING
THIS PROJECT ARE SIGNIFICANT.
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION HAS
WRITTEN EXTENSIVELY ABOUT THE
COST PER MILE INCREASES.
TRANSPORTING AGGREGATES IN THE
CASE OF SAN FERNANDO VALLEY IN
THE LOS ANGELES BASIN THERE'S
LESS THAN TEN YEARS OF AGRO
AGGREGATE RESERVES ACCORDING TO
PROMINENT CONSERVATION THIS
PROJECT WOULD ALLEVIATE THAT
PROBLEM AND STATE CALTRANS-
HEALTH OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AS WELL AS HOME BUILDERS AND
THEN THE ASSOCIATED GHG
EMISSIONS WERE TRANSPORTING
VERY HAPPY PRODUCT BUT BELIEVES
REASONS WE DO OPPOSE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU THAT'S A PRIMARY
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. THE REST
ARE ME TOO'S. MONTEREY ANYONE
ELSE OPPOSED TO SB. FIVE
TWENTY. I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON
SB FIVE TWENTY. MR WILL BE LIKE
CLOSE YES SIR THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS BY MISALIGNMENT HOLD
ON ONE SECOND. BY THE QUESTIONS
GO AHEAD SO. THEY HAVE. MISTER
WERE CONTENT TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL BUT AS YOU SAID IN YOUR
TESTIMONY THIS IS BEEN GOING ON
FOR THIRTY YEARS AND I'M REALLY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT FROM SOME OF
MY PAST INCARNATIONS. IS THIS
BILL GOING TO HELP RESOLVE THIS
AND GET TO THE END AND SOME
MORE. YEAH THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION WHICH I APPRECIATE
RIGHT NOW CEMEX IS SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THEY
THEY'VE TERM THEY TERMINATED
THOSE LEASES. SO IN AN IDEAL
WORLD THEY THEY LOSE AT
LITIGATION AND THEN THE PROJECT
DICE. BUT THE POINT OF THIS
BILL IS SIMPLY THAT IF THEY DO
MOVE FORWARD TO GET APPROVAL TO
MOVE FORWARD IT'S BEEN THIRTY
YEARS SINCE WE'VE LOOKED AT
THAT IN THIS WHOLE AREA AS YOU
GET WE HAD CLIMATE CHANGE
DROUGHT- THIS AREA NOW IS THE
THIRD LARGEST CITY IN L. A.
COUNTY. I DON'T THINK WAS EVER
APPROPRIATE THIS PARTICULAR
PROJECT I WAS I WAS TOO LARGE
BUT- IT IS IT JUST IT JUST AND
IT'S NOT JUST IT'S NOT
COMPATIBLE WITH THE AREA SO ALL
THIS BILL DOES IS ALLOW THE
LOCAL PUBLIC TO WEIGH IN. ON
THE IMPACT TO THE LOCAL WATER
SUPPLY THAT'S ALL THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THAT WAS OF
FISCAL QUESTION THANK YOU. YOU
KNOW GIVEN THE FACT OF YOUR
FORMER ROLE- YOU'VE TOTALLY
ENTITLED TO THAT QUESTION.
THANK YOU SEE NO OTHER
QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE BECKLEY ASPIRIN I VOTE
DO WE HAVE A MOTION THIS IS A
DO PASSED MISS COM LONGER. HAS
MADE A MOTION TO- MOVE THE BILL
TO THE FLOOR MR SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE BILL
FIVE TWENTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO I PORTANTINO AYE
BRADFORD HI JONES. KAMLAGER HI
MARGARET ARE LAYERED HI LAYERED
BY WORKOUTS SKI HI KELSEY ARE
WE WILL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR
MEMBERS TO ADD ON WE ARE IN THE
HOME STRETCH HERE THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU MR
WEALTH BUT WILL MOVE TO MISTER
TODD I WAS SB THREE EIGHTY FIVE
FUND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES- SHE HAS WAY
PRESENTATION THIS IS A SUSPENSE
CANDIDATE. AND WILL GO TO
SUPPORT THERE'S NO ONE IN THIS
ROOM IN SUPPORT THIS NOMINEE
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN SUPPORT
FOR ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE EIGHT
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
SUPPORT OF S. B. THREE EIGHT
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I DO HAVE
ONE IN Q. IT'LL JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THAT COMMENT. BY
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT DO.
OR AS AN- ADD B. EIGHTY TWO NO
S. B. EIGHTY TWO IS AN HOUR
AGO- SO THANK YOU WILL MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT PERSON PLEASE.
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
SP THREE EIGHTY FIVE C. NO ONE
IN THIS ROOM SAYING NO ONE IN
TWENTY FORTY TO ANYONE ON THE
PHONE LINE OPPOSED TO SP. THREE
EIGHTY FIVE. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB THREE EIGHT
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE EIGHT
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT- HAVING
OFFERED SUPPORT OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS NOT
HAVE A FILE. NO QUESTIONS FROM
MY COLLEAGUES WITHOUT OBJECTION
SB THREE EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE. STRUCTURE LETTER
EUROPE YOU'VE BEEN PATIENT ALL
DAY. PLEASE COME PRESENT AS
BEFORE- SEVEN ON PROFESSIONAL
LAND SURVEYORS THIS IS A
ELIGIBLE FOR DO PASSED MOTION
SENATOR ARCHULETA TELL US ABOUT
SB FOUR OH SEVEN. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL FOUR OH
SEVEN THIS MEASURE UPDATES THE
LANGUAGE COVERING THE SCOPE OF
PRACTICE FOR LAND SURVEYORS.
DURING THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
TO COME TO OUR ATTENTION THAT
THIS ISSUE IS PART OF A LARGER
DISCUSSION BETWEEN LABOR GROUPS-
DUE TO THIS I WOULD LIKE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MOVE THE BILL
OUT OF THE COMMITTEE AND ONTO
THE SENATE FLOOR. I COMMIT TO
ALL PARTIES THAT I WILL
CONTINUE WORKING WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WILL NOT MOVE
THE BILL UNTIL WE HAVE COME TO
A COMPROMISE. I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU MR
ARCHULETA- WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S
ANY TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
SAYING NO ONE IN THIS ROOM SHE
KNOWN IN TWENTY FORTY IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR OH SEVEN.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. FIRST A PORT OF
S. B. FOUR ZERO SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I DO HAVE ONE LINE IN Q.
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR
THEIR COMMENT. NINE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEDICARE
SENATE CHAIRMAN'S REQUEST TO
LIMIT TESTIMONY- THE FISCAL
CONCERN BUT HAVEN'T BEEN ASKING
ABOUT READING JUNIORS BUT IT.
TO CLARIFY AND WHEN THE
SURVEYOR IS NOT REQUIRED TO BE
USED WE BELIEVE THE WHOLE- THE
BOARD LIMIT COMPLAIN TO. INTO
THE PORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FOR COMMENTS THANK YOU
IT THIS TIME ALL RIGHT WELL
MOVED OPPOSITION SEEING NOBODY
IN THIS ROOM OPPOSING OWNER
ROOM TWENTY FORTY OPPOSED. TO
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE OPPOSE
THIS BEFORE OF SEVEN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB FOUR ZERO
SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
ALL RIGHT WE WILL OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION APARTMENT OF FINANCE
DOES NOT HAVE A FILE ON SB FOUR
OH SEVEN- BEFORE WE CLOSE AS
YOU KNOW HANDS GO UP. MISTER
TAYLOR I APPRECIATE YOU MAKING
A COMMITMENT NOT TO MOVE THE
BILL OFF TE FLOOR UNTIL THERE
IS A- AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
PARTIES TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
CORRECT AND WITH THAT MEMBERS I
RECOMMENDED TO PASS. IS YEAH WE
HAVE A MOTION FIVE LARRY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENT ONCE AGAIN I THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CONSULT WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATE BILL FOUR OH
SEVEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO HI.
TINA HI BATES. BRADFORD ALL
RIGHT BRADFORD HI JONES. KAMBAR
HI I'M LONGER ARE LAYERED HI
THERE HI MY COUNTY. HI CASKEY
BY BOTH SIDES OF THE BILL'S
FIVE OR TWELVE IT OVER FOR FOLK
TO COME BACK AND ADD ON WE HAVE
TO GO TO BILLS LEFT MEMBERS
pARCHER LETTER THAT BILL WILL
GET OUT. OF WILL MOVE ON SB
FOUR SIXTY ONE BY MISTER
CORTESE ON UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAWS- HE IS WAY PRESENTATION
AND IT IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATES.
AND WE'LL GO RIGHT TO SUPPORT
TESTIMONY OF SB FORTY TWO OH
THREE. SHIMMY IN ROOM FORTY TWO
OH THREE THERE'S NO ONE HERE IS
SUPPORT FOR SIXTY ONE WILL GO
TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY NOBODY
THEIR MODERATORS ANYBODY ON THE
PHONE LINE IT'S SUPPORT OF SB
FOUR SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. FOUR SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN FIRST A PART OF S.
B. FOUR SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE BONTA
GONNA BE AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA STATE
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL. IN THE
WESTERN STATES KILL SOCIABLE OF
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NINE ONE
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TO THE CHAIR AND
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS KARTIK RAJ CALLING ON
BEHALF OF JUSTICE TO EXPRESS
OUR SUPPORT FOR SB FOUR SIXTY
ONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME RIGHT WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION- THERE'S NOBODY IN
THIS ROOM OPPOSE THIS BEFORE
SIXTY ONE THERE'S NOBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY MODERATORS OR
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE
OPPOSED SP FOUR SIXTY ONE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SP FOUR SIX
ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. FOR OPPOSITION OF
SB FOUR SIX ONE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THIS IS ONE THE PROPOSAL. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME ALL HAVING
HEARD FROM SUPPORT OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT FINANCES NOT HAVE A
FILE AND IT'S BEFORE SIXTY ONE
MY COLLEAGUES DO NOT HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION AS
BEFORE SIXTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE YOUR LAST BILL OF THE
DAY SB FIVE FOUR FOUR BY
SENATOR LARRY WHO IS GRACIOUS
THE WAY PRESENTATION AND THIS
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE SEEING
NO ONE IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE
IN SUPPORT OF SB FIVE FOUR
FOUR. ON CANNABIS TESTING A
SINGLE ONE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
IN SUPPORT MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ON THE PHONE LINE IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FOUR FOUR. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
SB FIVE FOUR FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONCE AGAIN FOR SUPPORT OF S. B.
FIVE FOUR FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. THE.
AFFECT ON THE STATE FARM I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMON SAYING
HE AT THIS ALL RIGHT WE'LL MOVE
COMPOSITIONS NOBODY IN FORTY
TWO OH THREE OPPOSE SEE NUMBER
THE IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
OPPOSES OR ANYONE ON THE PHONE
LINE OPPOSED SB FIVE FOUR FOUR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FOUR
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN FOR
OPPOSITION OF SB FIVE FOUR FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT HAVING OFFER THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS NOT HAVE A FILE AND
SB FIVE FOUR FOUR SEEING NO
QUESTIONS FROM MY COLLEAGUES
WITHOUT OBJECTION SB FIVE FOUR
FOUR. WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE-
BACK INCLUDES OUR FILE COPY
HAVE A NUMBER OF ITEMS OPEN
WHICH WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH
THE ROLE RIGHT NOW OUR FIRST
ONE IS S. B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT.
GEO COMMITTEE BILL DODD. MR
SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL ON S.
B. EIGHT ONE EIGHT FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. WITH SB EIGHT
ONE EIGHT MOTION IS TO PASS THE
SENATE FLOOR CURRENT. FORTY
ZERO. YOUR VOTING I ADVISED HER
BY BRADFORD OFF BRADFORD BY.
KAMLAGER HI COMMA ARE QUITE SKI
HI CASKEY ARE. SO THE BILL IS
OUT YOU WILL MOVE ON S. TWO
EIGHT EIGHT FIVE SAN JOHN
MISTER SIR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
FOR A BILL TO EIGHTY PROMOTIONS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR
CURRENT. SIX TWO ZERO CHAIR
VOTING BY CENTER BATES SENATOR
BATES FIVE THE BILL HAS SEVEN
ALL RIGHT THEN WE HAVE SB FIVE
TWENTY BY SENATOR WILL WHICH IS
OPEN ROLE MR SURPLUS. THE I'M
SORRY THE BILL IS OUT AS WE TWO
EIGHT EIGHT BY SENATOR JONES IS
OUT. SEVEN ZERO OKAY. WITH
SEVEN VOTES DOT THE BUTTER OUT
WE'LL MOVE ON FIVE TWENTY BY
SENATOR WILL. SB FIVE YEAH. ONE
SEVERAL. THAT'S FIRST BILL
TWENTY BY SEN WORLD PROMOTIONS
TO PASS THE SENATE FLOOR-
CURRENT FIVE- CHAIRMAN I'D
BATES. BATES FIVE JONES I JONES
BY THE BILL TO STEP BILL IS OUT
ON SO VOTES. MOVE ON TO OUR
FINE BILL ON CALL AS BEFORE- OH
SEVEN BY SENATOR ARCH ALETTA
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SENATE BILL FOUR ZERO SEVEN THE
MOTIONS TO PASS THE SENATE
FLOOR CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ZERO
CHAIR VOTING. CENTER BATES.
EIGHT TO FIVE JONES BY JONES
FIVE LEVELS BILLS THAT PHILIP
OUT OF SPEAK- SEVEN WITH SOME
VOTES- THAT CONCLUDES OUR-
DOCKET FOR TODAY SO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED IN
THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO. SPEAK TODAY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE OR
VISIT OUR WEBSITE. YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOU IN THE TESTIMONY NO
THERE WAS AT LEAST ONE PERSON
WANTED TO ADD ADDITIONAL
TESTIMONY SO PLEASE SEND THAT
IN. THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION WE
CONCLUDED THE AGENDA AND THE
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WILL ADJOURN. THANK YOU.